the only reason I'm delaying is that uh
YouTube is not up and spinning yet so I
just want to make sure that we keep the
public in the loop they'll start it once
you once you open the meeting
chicken and egg okay all right so it's a
little past 10 o'clock
um division three work session is uh is
now open
um if uh for those of you who have
looked into the calendar uh you'll see
that we have time this morning to where
we're going to do the division of
Medicaid services and then at one
o'clock it says that we're going to do a
work session on HB 527 okay so so my my
concept of of what we're going to end up
doing here today is that we're going to
hear from the department and from some
uh some interest groups about rate
setting and what kind of recommendations
they have for the coming budget year as
you know the the governor initiated the
discussions around a across the board
3.1 percent a Medicaid increase and in
his verbal remarks pointed out that he
was open to us moving some money around
to Target things a little bit better so
so today is about our listening our not
making any commitments but our coming to
understand
where the department may lead us to
believe that we have some potential
flexibility in how we prioritize one
service over another
and while we're doing that
for those of you that have looked at HB
527 it's a pretty narrow very specific
bill
it touch it's it's an example of a great
many
services for which a Medicaid rate
increase is being requested and so my
hope is that we will look at
the recommendation of 527 and the
broader context of what the department
has to present so that we have a
holistic view of what 527 means I I
would not be surprised if we ended up
incorporating whatever we choose to do
ultimately into the budget process and
and then that way we would be able to
dispose of the bill 527 while we still
addressed its content and then after
that at two o'clock we've got the dcyf
that is also going to be talking to us
so so there's a lot to do today I I
don't know if we're going to be able to
get to it all
um and uh so let's go ahead and get
good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services
good morning for the record Henry
and as a chairman Edwards already
indicated we will be presenting on the
division of Medicaid services this
morning and before you you should have
the budget briefing book for the
division of Medicaid services and then
you will also have the presentation that
we will be covering this morning and so
with that I will hand it over to Henry
so so I flip through this what what page
um well we were going to start with the
with the presentation oh the
understanding the time that you're
trying to work through I'm not going to
read every slide I'm going to try to
highlight some points on the various
slides here
um so on beginning on uh slide two under
the mission just would highlight as many
might recognize there are more people on
Medicaid today than ever before in New
Hampshire but even with that
nationally as of October was the latest
statistics New Hampshire had the fourth
lowest enrollment in Medicaid in the
country
today it's about one in 5.5 individuals
nationally it runs anywhere between one
turning to slide three at the top I
think you know distinguishing you know
Medicare from Medicaid but in the
Medicaid Program today we're just above
250 000 as of the end of January it was
just under
um and then I think in terms of the
division of Medicaid services we sort of
have two functions if you will in the
department one is sort of like the
health insurance program that you're
familiar with the other is sort of being
the the connection with CMS in terms of
all the waivers and state plans and
assisting other divisions with the
opportunities to draw Medicaid funds as
opposed to having to use General funds
from the state and there's a list there
um
going to as long as you're on that 250
on page three yes after we get done with
the wind down what's what's the
anticipated participation level I have a
slide on that but we're in terms of by
the end of this calendar we're
anticipating that about just under 59
000 will be subtracted from this uh
number and then eventually over another
year because some people who are newer
to the program have a year to of
Eligibility before their subject to uh
um doing a redetermination of their
eligibility so we're expecting that by
December we'll have I'm seeing a drop of
about
um 59 000 and I'll have a few slides
that get into that in more detail okay
question
thank you very much can you just wear
the fourth lowest in the nation can you
just give us some background on why that
is is it because we're doing that much
better than the rest of the nation or
because it's a lack of knowledge of the
of the system
I would
um if you look at it broadly New
Hampshire's economy is stronger than
um you know at the other end of the
spectrum Mississippi New Mexico
communities that have a lot higher
percentage of poverty tend to have a
much higher level of enrollment that
while Medicaid is largely a categorical
program income does come in in terms of
Eligibility and assets and so New
Hampshire you know overall has had a
lower than average for a long time it's
actually in some categories for example
children New Hampshire's eligibility is
higher than some states in terms of
allowing children to to qualify for the
program so I think it's a function of
welcome representative nordgren how are
I'm so sorry do we have a question over
here I do uh and yeah definitely it's
nice to have you back too
um
uh you mentioned that we're fourth lease
do you have any comments about the
intensity and breadth of services uh
dollars per per uh Medicaid recipient
and how that compares to other states so
I think when you've seen one Medicaid
Program you've seen one Medicaid Program
as part of the the function but I guess
in terms of the way I would Express it
is that against the president's Trend if
you're familiar with with that and um
uh uh on B budgeting at a at a federal
level that we've consistently come under
that Trend in terms of our increase in
spending I think function also of
certain categories relative to the
supply of providers you know New
Hampshire has historically not been a
um
over bedded or an over provided state so
some of that factors into what the cost
looks like and also just New England
with heating costs and other things and
the labor markets just is a little bit
more expensive place to do business
generally
follow up
uh are are you saying there may be more
need than we're we're able to service
and that's
um keeping the spend down a bit
um there I guess in terms of appropriate
utilization I think what we're seeing in
some and why the I think the chair was
talking before the meeting began about
you know the uh stakeholders who are
interested in further rate increases I
think that
um there are areas of the program
um for example home care where there are
shortages of personnel and where we're
not able to deliver 100 of the if you
will documented hours of care that might
be needed
um you know obviously in the the mental
health space that is you know prominent
in the news that there's a shortage of
Workforce here
um that's comparable and some other
places but part of the the
thing that we're tracking is sort of
pre-pandemic levels of utilization
versus where we are today we're still
not back to where we were in 2019
in some categories
so I like to try to keep things simple
just to make sure I'm understanding them
and and so that the public if they're
watching can follow along
um so our utilization is tied to a
couple of things one the amount of money
that we're putting into the system to to
to purchase supplies and capability and
then the other the number of people who
work in the field and that and that so
it is possible for us to put
more money into the system and still yet
have a limitation built in on
utilization because
we don't have the people to provide the
services is is that is that a possible
outcome of of a policy decision we might
end up making here
I wish it was that simple it's a little
bit more complicated than that and so as
an example you know part of utilization
is driven by the the demographic Trends
in the state you know in terms of the
older we get the the more utilization
um you know services like maternity they
can vary too in terms of what the birth
rate is and um you know inba in
migration out migration in the state but
in terms of looking at in the short term
you know looking at basically the
utilization that's potentially
out there to be had like in outpatient
mental health treatment
or home care or some of the other
ones where we have severe shortages of
capacity you know I think that that
you're right on on those points but I
think it gets to be a little bit more
complicated like one of the major areas
of the Medicaid budget that's growing is
in Pharmacy
um Pharmacy is is now the second largest
expenditure and I can tell you
um on the
on the horizon in terms of the types of
therapies that are available you know
one that we've had happen already is a
therapy called zolgensma which uh just
the dose of the the uh
it's a gene therapy actually the dose of
the gene therapy costs 2.4 million not
to mention the hospitalization and other
things that go around it so some of what
is out there to come in terms of Gene
therapies and the like are you know
they're relatively rare but we've had
instances of those occur and that's in
terms of driving the budget in the
future that's that's an area that isn't
so much necessarily driven by any of
those factors but by science and what's
huh
just continuing on slide four one of the
things I
um mentioned a Health and Human Service
oversight on Friday is I think taking a
broader view of Medicaid Medicaid I
think is part of a policy solution in
the state
um you know I already covered that with
a fourth lowest population but part of
the functioning of our insurance markets
is a function of the risk that's there
to underwrite and so
um by the move that was made
back in 2019 to bring the expansion
population into back into the Medicaid
Managed Care Program it it affected the
individual Market
um and in that space if you look at the
footnote at the bottom
New Hampshire had the lowest Benchmark
premium in the United States in 2022 and
we were the number one in terms of the
percentage of employer sponsored
coverage in in the United States
so I think in terms of the the health of
the the market if you will I know
insurance is expensive not trying to
Discount that but on a relative basis
those are two good indicators
um another one I would um highlight is
that uh the number of people working in
New Hampshire
um that are on Medicaid has increased
since 2019 we're up to 70 percent that
are working to some level
um and
um we were we're higher than the
national average in that as well and so
I think in blue there what I'm the
conclusion I draw is that the
combination of what the insurance
department has done with their 1332
waiver by moving the expansion
population back into the Medicaid
Managed Care Program you know it has put
us in a better position as a state to
so that that's that was sort of a eye
level thing and pausing on on page
five here um I know some people are
um uh have had less interaction with the
Department on on Medicaid so I wanted to
pause here in terms of if there were any
of these topics on page five that
anybody would like a little sort of
background before diving into the rest
of the the presentation
so so thank you for that invitation and
I I just would want to re-emphasize that
for the folks who are newer to the
division three and to Health Care this
is really your opportunity to just say
hey this looks interesting let's talk
representative Mooney
thank you and thank you both for being
here the question regarding chip how
does that relate to other programs for
instance New Hampshire Healthy Kids and
the like
so I think New Hampshire Healthy Kids
was the
the predecessor program to
um what is children's coverage today I
think there was an advantage at not sure
the year before my time back a number of
years ago that there was an advantage
from a financing standpoint to move the
children's population that was formerly
under healthy kids within back within
the Medicaid Program itself and so that
coverage is embedded in um and will be
in 47 10 705 one this is where we'll
talk about the children's health
representative
thank you could you touch on what the
state phase down
is sure that that one's a
um an interesting one an interesting one
when we get to it on the budget sheet so
going back maybe more than a decade in
terms of people who are what we call
dual eligible both have Medicaid in
Medicare that the state has some
responsibility to pick up part of their
prescription drug costs and each year
the federal government publishes
typically around October what the rate
is for the next year and so
um when we get to that section one of
the things it's a fairly straightforward
calculation our rate is I think
233.44 cents for the next year time
multiplied times the number of
individuals that we expect to be having
to pay for which is approximately a
little over nineteen thousand
um and that's how we arrive at the
number that's been an area of the budget
that last session in this session we
haven't quite penetrated through in
terms of how this number is budgeted and
we had a shortage over what is in the
the agency compared to the governor's
budget of about 15 million over the
biennium on that account and
historically we've had to make it up
somewhere else
and and and and just her context in 22
um we came about eight million dollars
short that we had to transfer to cover
that we're projecting a similar uh
looks like you can continue no other
questions
so um the the next uh page is sort of
um
I guess almost like a table of contents
I know we want to go through next the
the budget briefing book but here again
is another menu of where you might want
us to we can go in any order you'd like
because we kind of organized it so that
we can pivot around where you'd like to
to go next but I think if
if there are any more background
questions
so I'll tell you what I'm chomping at
the bit to see your spreadsheet on
current and proposed Medicaid rates and
what the financial impact of moving
money around would be that that's where
my head's at today I mean
can we do that or I know I'm going to
ask you to fast forward through a lot of
this uh is there something in here
that's foundational to us to get into
that I think one of the the areas that I
think is important to understand
not only from a budget standpoint but
from a constituent standpoint what's
happening with the the unwind and how
we're preparing for that
um I would like I know you got a good
dose of it at uh at Health and Human
Service oversight but um I know
um with you know 58 000 or more uh maybe
close to 60 000 people
um who are going to be losing Medicaid
that
um that's our estimate anyways that that
you'll I'm expecting that will lead to
interact to help consumers which slide
would you like us on oh um could we go
through the briefing book first I'm
really trying to get to your Excel
spreadsheet on categories and proposed
and existing rates that that's
all right
um so maybe if we've got a slide 43
representative walner has a question
I know you're anxious to get to a
certain spreadsheet but I I think it
would be helpful if we could have Mr let
me go through his presentation we do
have new people here
and I mean for myself I even don't
really remember all of this so just I
think it would be helpful to do that and
then we'll we'll get to the spreadsheet
I'm sure I'll I'll be judicious on time
if that's the way you want me to go yeah
yeah I mean it's all written here and we
can ask follow-up questions via email
and to ask you back for things we don't
understand so so yeah go ahead and and
let's let's do the foundational stuff
so we'll come back to the briefing but
okay
so I I'll skip over the
so let me start with um slide
and
um
so one of the things
um we're pleased to be able to report
New Hampshire
um has been working on the department
has been working on preparing for this
unwind since July of 2020.
um I think there are press accounts over
the weekend that cited New Hampshire as
able to begin its unwind among the
earliest among states where we're able
to begin with actually disenrollment of
people who aren't eligible beginning
April some states are taking to July we
also have an indication that unlike some
other states we don't have to have a
mitigation plan because our eligibility
system and our systems of doing things
we had unlike some states we also never
stopped doing our business
we work with people on a voluntary basis
saying you know it makes sense to to do
your redetermination and we got over 32
000 people to do it on a voluntary basis
and we had the number in the slide deck
says 2000 in the middle on page 10 in
terms of people no longer
needing Medicaid they're telling us you
know I've got something else that's now
up to 2 400. so we've been proactive to
try to get some of the work done ahead
of time
um and uh We've also in terms of
you know while we talk about the
disenrollment we you know the key thing
that we're trying to do from a messaging
standpoint internally and with the
public is that if you're eligible for
Medicaid the reason we did all this
advanced work we want to make sure
people who are eligible don't lose
coverage and so we're making extra
efforts there and on the last one we've
been working with the insurance
department with
um the federal government's consumer
information Insurance oversight provided
in fact we have created a pilot with
them to individuals who are over income
who might otherwise not do anything they
otherwise would typically like a dead
letter they would they wouldn't go
anywhere so we've got a mechanism to
send them back to them so that if they
can qualify for another source of
coverage
um and we were the first state in the
country to to come up with that
um so that that's slide 10 slide 11. can
you pause or representative hole has a
question thank you chair so looking at
bullet point two right of the 32 000 and
now 2 400 individuals
does that number include or not include
let's say those who passed away and what
does that leave is total enrollment
still remaining
So today we're at about 250 000
individuals this wouldn't include
anybody that passed away this is just
people who on a voluntary basis
completed their redetermination so our
we can disenroll people who've passed
away or who let us know they've moved to
another state and our numbers all
reflect that
um in terms of from last session on page
um you know this
this committee and the Health and Human
Service and elderly Affairs
passed the adult Dental benefit we're on
track to make April 1st we still have to
meet the mandatory requirement and of
having all the sign offs from CMS we
believe that we're going to make those
and be able to start April 1.
um
in terms of uh in and out Medicaid that
was something that the eligibility
limits hadn't been touched in more than
a decade those were to be implemented by
January 1 we did so we also implemented
the rate increases that were passed into
the law last session to help maternity
care at hospitals and birthing centers
moving to slide 12 waivers up the we've
had a substance use disorder waiver
basically the substance use disorder and
what we described as SMI severely
mentally ill what this allows the state
to do is to claim Federal match where we
otherwise wouldn't have been able to to
support
those services that are on an inpatient
basis with the understanding that we
would use the the money that we sort of
free up to continue to make sure that
we're not replacing our community-based
services which the state has been
investing inevidently over the past
couple of sessions that that we have to
prove that we're you know not trying to
institutionalize people and I think we
received the sud component in 18 an
amendment that included the the the
mental health in in 2020 and we're have
an extension uh that is under
consideration another point of that one
is uh as as County delegation
individuals who'd be interested in is
that CMS is now issued or is about to
issue guidance that allows for Medicaid
to pick up some expenses for
incarcerated individuals in the
pre-release period we had asked for an
option of that and I think eventually
we'll be able to offer that to support
people re-entry successfully as well as
will be some I think help to the cost
that's incurred by our correction system
both at a state and county level
ultimately
um
moving to slide 13 in terms of Staffing
last time last time I came before you
for Budget we had 100 vacancy even our
eight positions in in mmis we've been
able to fill six of those positions
which is an accomplishment I believe in
this in this world and then you know
basically our our staffing is a we have
a lot of specialized position and
sometimes it takes us a number of months
to fill positions and Key Personnel
right now I need to fill a deputy
director position than the person who
does my state plans or two vacancies
that I have there kind of specialized
situations
um moving to slide 14 and 15
uh these are just uh a couple of slides
that if you want to look at different
attributes of the New Hampshire program
versus the United States
and again in the interest of time I'll
um
I'll uh go I'll not go over this in
detail but just maybe highlight that if
you compare
um
on page 14 sort of the second section
eligibility levels
the United States for children the the
eligibility level is 255 percent in New
Hampshire it's 323 percent
um you know for pregnant women we're a
little bit lower than the national
average by four percent in eligibility
but the rest of them are pretty
consistent with the national average but
I think it just reflects the importance
of kids in in the culture of New
Hampshire and
Mr chair
go ahead so is it possible to get the
data that's shown on slides 14 and 15
relative to comparing New Hampshire
versus the rest of the U.S comparing
showing it as bar graphs relative to all
the other states it's not necessarily
a fair comparison to take us and compare
us to let's say the southern states
or states that aren't as had enjoy such
high employment
I think um there this uh particular
chart I can send a link to the committee
that you can pull down any state in the
country and do a comparison if that
would that would be great thank you okay
and the disclaimer here this is not this
is not New Hampshire's data this is data
that was aggregated by the Kaiser Family
Foundation and some of the underlying
data may not be as accessible as it
question represents stream
um in the table with comparing to the
federal poverty level like seniors it's
they have to be three quarters of the
federal poverty level to even be
eligible is that what this says in in
certain categories I think the
eligibility pieces
we could spend quite a bit of time on
that and I have someone who's a subject
matter expert on that but in certain
areas just I think
being older without any other condition
um slide
16 and 17 are
two ways of looking
at enrollment this one slide is updated
through February 13th and the the pivot
point on the left hand side of the graph
on page 16
is where we began when things began to
come into place with respect to
um
the president's order at the time in
terms of the public health emergency and
and all that you can see that
continuous enrollment has led to a lot
the largest increases in the granted
Advantage Program
um 86 and a half percent and if kind of
the spike on that right was if you
remember there was a short time where
unemployment New Hampshire spiked up to
17 in some places 25 percent and
individuals who became eligible in that
period due to the continuous enrollment
requirements to draw the additional
money from the federal government
so once they became enrolled ordinarily
we'd see a churn there in fact I think
we have a slide somewhere in in the deck
as well it talks about typically how
long someone spends on granite Advantage
it's not it's a program where we've had
000 different individuals since I think
2014 who've been on the program
ordinarily we've been averaging about in
the fifty thousand 152
000 range and so this is extraordinarily
extraordinary growth and and uh I think
reflected the the the hit to the
temporary hit to the economy where a lot
of people became eligible who lost their
positions
um
on page 17 you can see we've created
three maps by county in terms of the
growth by county and you can see in
terms of granted Advantage it wasn't
isolated to one County it was all over
the map so to speak
um and you can look at the other
programs where there's a lesser amount
of growth
Paige
um
18 sort of another look at it by looking
at it by the end of February
jumping onto page 19
um
so
this is where I was talking about where
we expect the disenrollment to come from
people who have
maintained continuous eligibility
um
and they're sort of broken into two
groups the smaller group that almost 29
000 are people who have completed their
redetermination
um but say largely or over income but
are protected
um and then there's the group that's
nearly 73 000 that are people who have
not
um completed it on a voluntary basis and
that number would be over a hundred
thousand if we weren't for the work we
had done
um earlier so the total protected
population is about a hundred and almost
a hundred and two thousand and these
numbers reflect
um we've updated them for the new
federal poverty limits that went into
effect uh or go into effect uh I think
in March one so this gives you a
snapshot there were about 1700
individuals that benefited from the from
the higher poverty uh levels
um so so I think you're hinting around
it but what explain exactly what you
mean by protected protected by what and
what are the implications of that so
when we talk about the protected means
that if it weren't for the continuous
enrollment Provisions that were
originally under the federal Public
Health emergency and then extended with
an end date through the Consolidated
appropriation act that was passed in
December that created a definitive end
date which was March 31st of continuous
enrollment were not for this under
normal business operations that most of
these people would likely not continue
to be eligible some in the 73 000 may
have information that says that they are
eligible and that's if you kind of look
at this number from a large standpoint
it's about 60 percent of this page that
we think will no longer be on Medicaid
we think a large percentage of the
pending and eligible may be able to be
eligible for exchange coverage or may
have had a change in circumstance that
allows them to get employer-based
insurance so this gets us back to that
same 59 000 number that you cited
exactly earlier we take a percentage of
the 101 000 that we think will remain in
the program
slide coming up that goes in that little
more detail
um
page 20 is the sort of just the
definitions that I just talked about 21
gives you a picture of the ineligible
excuse me the protected population you
can see that the granite Advantage
population is the largest one and you'd
expect that there to be a good amount of
turnover in this group because it's
typically a program people don't stay on
for the long term the one that concerns
me as the Medicaid director and should
concern us all is that the children and
making sure that none of them lose
coverage
unnecessarily there is part of the
Consolidated appropriation Act is
providing children one year of
continuous coverage starting January 1
of 24. and I'll talk a little bit about
how we've factored that in but we've
done a lot of Outreach on the far right
to the and we've done that with the mcos
we've done that with providers and other
stakeholders to to work the right hand
side of the chart and the other groups
to a lower level and we still hope to
make further progress on on that in the
coming weeks and months
if you go to slide 22
this is the
the first slide we look at the 102 000
roughly was looking at an individual
basis but that's actually not how we
typically do eligibility we do it on a
household basis and and think about that
as if you had a household of four people
why come back over and over again to do
the eligibility we do it on a household
basis and so these are just household
numbers
um moving to slide 23
um
what we have here is each state in order
to begin the unwind had to present to
CMS a plan of how they could you hold
for a question here in order
thank you Mr chair
um could you talk a little bit about the
overdue redetermination is that an
employment issue in your department or
what would be the definition of that so
under the federal Public Health
Emergency and then under the
Consolidated appropriation act
individuals did not it was voluntary to
complete every determination
um some some states didn't even do
voluntary predeterminations we continued
to do where people were interested in
protecting themselves and doing them in
advance what we try to get a message out
is you don't want to wait till
everybody's doing at the same time we
want to kind of spread the workload out
a bit and so these are individuals for
whatever reason haven't taken advantage
of the voluntary situation it may very
well be that some won't apply but
they're just they just haven't had to do
it and we can't force them to do it we
as of March 31st that option of not
so it wasn't because of your situation
in the department it was because the
people were applying and they weren't
following up they didn't they weren't
required from an eligibility standpoint
um
so the Distribution on page 22 the sort
of the middle chart there is the number
of redeterminations we plan to be doing
what we call full redeterminations
um on a monthly basis including those
that are in the the 102 000 plus all the
the ones that uh or the 73 000 that all
those that we um plan to do plus our
regular work of people who came on later
who are there redeterminate
determination dates coming up one of the
things that is a condition that's
reflected in this chart is we can't do
everybody at once we have to we have to
spread the workload out so that we can
don't end up having this big issue over
and over again so that's what's
representative very quick question how
are you guys determining
um who you deal with first is there any
logic to that or is it random it there
is definitely logic to it um great yeah
the
if you turn to the next uh slide 24 out
um
on the far right
um towards the on the top chart you'll
see the numbers that I've been talking
about the 72 802 the 101
um thousand and the 28 000 996 that
that's what you saw earlier on that
three block chart
um what you see on the left hand side
are the groupings of different
eligibility groups what we tried to do
is we ran data to look at people who
have been on the program who have not
used services and actually it's it's a
fairly large percentage particularly in
the in the in some groups and so that
the people who have you know had we've
been paying a premium but uh aren't
using the services that's who we're
looked at
rolling off first those who we think are
likely to be eligible someone in a
nursing home someone who's in CFI
someone who has a mental illness someone
who has a severe medical condition we've
tried to move them further out
um in the in the unwind and so that 73
000 individuals you can see that some
have a new redetermination date that
would take them as far out as
um you know the end of the year but most
of it's done by September
um
and what we've tried to do is
work with our mcos and providers to
identify those individuals where we've
seen High utilization where we're
concerned that they have an underlying
medical condition that might be
affecting their ability to that we're
doing extra Outreach in fact we've
called everybody on this list multiple
times on an outbound basis and we've
given lists to our MCO and and some key
stakeholder providers like Mental Health
Centers area agencies federally
qualified Health Centers of lists of
their patients what was missing from
them to complete their redetermination
so that we can get them to also
participate in helping get the message
out to individuals
and the the numbers in red there are
what we estimate to close now this is
basically developed based on experience
of closure and more normal circumstances
will be tracking this stuff see how this
actually plays out
um
then the second chart uh there is the
the pending and eligible group today I
mentioned there's nearly 29 000
individuals that are within their
12-month of redetermination they've done
it already but there's a a group of
about 7 300 by the time we get to
actually being able to do this that will
require us to go through another full
redetermination with them but the rest
of them will have an opportunity to let
us know if there's a change in
circumstances but we don't have to go
through a full redetermination on the
almost 22 000 people the 21 687
um and then what you'll see is if you
look at this chart that we expect the
earlier months to have a higher closure
rate than the lower months in the later
months because again we picked to unwind
people who generally haven't been using
Services more um as being the
individuals to work with first
let me stop there that's a that's a lot
um
thank you where in the budget would we
see the expected savings from this
roll-off process so in 7948 and 79 51 is
where the budget reflects the unwind
um
so Mr White would you tell us the page
number that uh Mr Lemon is referring to
sure so in in the governor's recommended
budget if if you turn to page uh 922
um that that's the account for standard
Medicaid
um that that would be impacted and then
um hmm
and then uh page 923 as well
um can we stay on 9 22 a second sure
crosswalk us what line you would have us
place
the the the impact would be to
um
so that if there are more individuals
enrolled in Medicaid the per member per
month cost would increase and and it
would be an impact there so so this is
the problem with us looking at different
documents I I I'm not sure I know what
line item you're on I'm on page 922 yep
in the in the uh first words there are
Health and Social Services zero five yep
so if if you move down then you'll see
79.48 that's the Medicaid Care
Management account 79
48. and then slide
oh I see and I see in oh seven seven
nine four eight Medicaid Care Management
okay yeah now what and then if if you
slide down to 101 medical payments to
Providers yes sir I'm there yep and and
I think what's important to to point out
is we did submit a prioritized needs
request
um to cover the The increased cost
resulting
um from The Continuous enrollment
um and and I believe the LBA had
provided the committee with the
preliminary hb2 general fund
Appropriations
um and right and we the included in the
governor's
um what I anticipate to be included in
the governor is hb2 is 16.3 million
dollars of General funds to cover those
those increased enrollment figures
16.3 and FY 24. uh yeah it will be
appropriated for the biennium is my
understanding and it's coming out of the
state fiscal year 23 Surplus is the way
that it's currently proposed okay but
the 16.3 is for both fiscal both years
of the of the biennium I I haven't seen
the final hb2 language
um I I would assume it would either be
for the biennial or state fiscal year 24
though and that's supposed to be Surplus
you have another question there
representative thank you so if this is
what we would see the reduction
it appears like we're seeing an increase
or am I misreading that so I think if if
you recall I think we've had offline
conversation about this in terms of the
granted Advantage Program where we've
seen the 86 percent that was a that is
not reflected in these numbers right
this is just a non-grant Advantage yeah
so you don't expect to see a savings in
the non-grant advantage would you expect
to see some there but much much less
savings because people who generally
qualify for the the other programs you
know they're
um you know categorically eligible at
the age of the blind the disabled
um you know there's some groups that
will developmental disabled I mean those
are once they tend to get eligibility
there's
um you know so that'll make sense but
the numbers are going up not even
staying the same so we do we do have
expect that
um there is I think we've built in about
a three percent increase related to just
the cost of Medical Care
um and the prioritized need of
additional funding for other rate
increases are not reflected in these
numbers okay I know you can't show us
where the grant Advantage Program is in
the budget because it's not in the
budget but could you get us the
information that corresponds to that
program I think there's actually
um in your binder there's the
I can get I can get to easier just send
it to you but we do I think within some
of the information we provided
um there's reports on we're just refer
me to it'd be great thank you actually I
actually might have something here that
I can hand to you on the way out for
that thank you so so I'm slower than
most so 3.1 percent across the board
Medicaid rate that the governor is
requesting is not reflected or is
reflected in this 750 million dollar
line item on 24. it is not it is not but
a
factor for medical costs of three
percent is included okay so if if we
were to take the proposal we would
multiply this by another uh 3.1 percent
to get the real request yes
for this particular and so so all the
people looking at the budget have to
keep in their mind that this is not the
number we're appropriating where if we
go with the 3.1 percent in hb2 we're
appropriating 3.1 percent more than this
and then you're asking for another 16.3
on top of it is that 16.3 to help with
the 3.1 percent or is it to help with
the inflation rate what what's again
what's the justification for doing that
sure so I I one thing that we haven't
talked about
um one of the Key conditions of the
continuous enrollment was that we were
unallowed to disenroll individuals but
one of the key advantages of not doing
that was we were allowed an additional
6.2 percent uh match or fmap from from
the federal government and that's
phasing down so beginning
um the last quarter of the state fiscal
year we'll have the five percent then
we'll have the two and a half percent
for the first quarter of next year then
the one and a half percent and that's
based on the assumption that we will
disenroll those individuals through that
process however
um based on the plan uh that that the
team has been working on for a very long
time that that Henry just spoke to uh
relative to the disenrollment process we
will still have a higher than initially
anticipated uh or higher enrollment
figures and so that 6.3 is intended to
cover the costs of of the higher number
of enrollees in the program now the
the three percent the three percent rate
increase that that's that will be a what
I anticipate to be a separate hb2
provision when hb2 is released so those
are those are distinct and separate so
the enhanced fmap the five percent the
2.4 and then whatever
are those enhancements showing up in a
revenue line somewhere or those off
budget offset of expense I believe is
so we've we've we've built those figures
into the assumptions and and so that
that 16.3 million dollar uh general fund
hb2 appropriation in our original agency
request that was close to 25 or 26 back
in the fall but we've we've had we have
new updated figures and so we revised
that during the governor's phase
um we'll continue to look at that to see
if there is opportunity to revise that
further
um but but that that is based on the
projections that we have the five
percent phase down
um and the budget is built built on on
the information that we have there
um so
representative erf and then
representative I just put that in
different words the fact that the F map
is going away we're getting less money
from that the six months the 16.3 is
intended to backfill those reductions
as if you kind of think of this the
unwind is going to be like a slope it's
to help cover the slope down to where we
get back to a more normal the slope
being though you're not getting as much
money through the F map well the slope
being that not everybody the 58 000 as
an example aren't leaving April 1st
they're going to be leaving over the
course of now and until uh December of
uh I get that but is the is the 16.3
million meant to
substitute for the fact that you're
getting Less in the fmap or is it for
something else no I think the the net
effect is if the 6.2 historically has
been covering the increase in enrollment
as that's going down we need to fill
that hole a bit yes which is what those
funds are intended to do yes okay thank
you
so this is in a similar vein so you know
we're looking uh federal funds were just
under 500 million in 2022 with an
additional 182 million of other funds
and uh they've dropped down to just over
400 million so
um yeah
pretty substantial uh but yet despite
that the general fund um uh is only only
funding about 210 10 million uh for the
7948 account
um uh
so
um
I'm just trying to figure out where
you know where the rest of the backfill
is coming from
I'm not sure I'm following your question
I apologize so from 2022 to 20 I'm
comparing 2022 actual to 2024 Governors
recommended
I'm under
um 009 agency income which has three
subdivided categories uh federal funds
General funds and other funds
so
um
so you're with me so far yes so one
thing that that I I do want to point out
so if if you do look at the federal
funds line for 22 you have the the 400
481 million basically you have the 396
in-state fiscal year 23. now that
doesn't include the most recent accept
and expend item that we brought forward
uh that was just approved by GNC uh last
week and that was for 52. 51 million
so the other thing to keep in mind is
that
the both the agency budget and the
governor's budget were probably largely
prepared before but the knowing the end
of the federal Public Health Emergency
and then the continuous enrollment under
the Consolidated appropriation Act
okay thanks
um
uh I think I'll pass on the rest for now
um back to the slide decks 25 is just
we're gonna is a a dashboard that we're
going to have to be able to track
um what's going on and
um not going to go in detail here other
than subsequently when you have
questions and when we come to fiscal
committee and what have you uh we'll be
able to drill down and provide different
cuts on the data
and then slide uh 26 is
um the it's a table that shows the
federal matching percentage by state
fiscal year and quarters running through
25. if you go to the far right you can
see that in 25 it's back to fully
current law which is 50 for the standard
program 65 for breast and cervical
cancer 65 for the chip program and 90
for Family Planning and granted
Advantage but that's just a we talk
about about Federal matching percentage
that's what we're referring to
can I actually ask a quick question on
that because I've been trying to get an
answer to this you include Family
Planning here at 90 Federal so I've I've
asked for that response for that match
I've never been given a solid answer
like that they tell me it's kind of
variable it depends on what we apply for
what's the actual is it is it a straight
90 10 or is it something else
um
there may be some permutations but I
think the core program is 90 the the the
question that that I um that I believe
we had gone back and forth on and have
had discussions
um with Trisha Tilley the division of
Public Health Services director is that
the the maintenance of effort question
the match question if you look at the
regulations that that we have from the
federal government which I believe we
provided it doesn't specify and I know
she's been working on getting Clarity
around what that represents and I know
she'll be ready to talk to that tomorrow
course and some of that funding may not
be Medicaid funding this is the Medicaid
component only
um
the next section
um gets into uh let's let's take a pause
there for the folks new to division
three do you know what the distinction
are
between maintenance of effort and the
general funds match do you know what
those are
[Music]
one do it do a really quick description
of what those two things are and how
they're how they're different from each
other sure so
um simplistically and and I I think the
Medicaid Program is is a great example
of this if you look at the standard
Medicaid line on page 26 it's a 50 match
so we have to spend fifty dollars in
order to get fifty dollars from the
federal government
um TANF which which we talked about I
believe the week before that that's
that's more of a maintenance of effort
requirement where we need to spend a
threshold dollar amount so roughly 32
million dollars in order to receive the
federal 38 million dollars and if we
don't meet the maintenance of effort
then the subsequent year we get a
reduced amount of funding plus we Face a
penalty so there's almost a spiraling
effect
um to doing that so so again match
literally it's it's a match 50 50 or 65
35 whatever it might be versus
maintenance of effort where you have to
meet a certain level of spending in
order to receive a dollar amount that
and it may be that's just spending the
match gives you the mace the the uh the
minimum threshold but it may also be
that it does not or is it a separate
amount of money that has to be spent
from the match
the general fund match
so if we're talking Medicaid it's we
have to spend the money to get the money
so that for first
on the set of benefits that falls under
Family Planning
we pay a
we pay a premium or pay or pay a FIFA
service amount and then we then make the
federal claim so that's that's how that
one works
but is it possible the federal claim
equals the
what would be the general fund match
or is the general fund match on top of
the general fund expenditure happens
first and then we get reimbursed for
what is the federal responsibility so if
we pay out a hundred dollars we'll get
back 90. oh okay but if you're if your
Moe is if maintenance of effort in the
case of Medicaid means not reducing
eligibility
um criteria or making it harder to get
eligible during the
um the continuous enrollment period so
that's okay so Moe is a positive
Medicaid is not a dollar figure no it's
not a dollar figure but what you were
talking about in other instances it is a
dollar figure
correct
if if we're talking about
um like like specific Federal grant
awards that we're receiving I I mean
oftentimes like TANF you mentioned yeah
sure so so so tan if we have to spend a
certain threshold in order to receive
I'm not seeing other questions go ahead
oh wait representative uh is there
um any ceiling on these uh individual
programs or it's just based on need and
actual expenditures
the latter would be the answer
representative
to the maintenance of effort is sort of
its own ceiling is the way I understand
it you have to cross that and you don't
have to spend above that but you have to
cross that and then the match is is
with Medicaid Medicaid maintenance
effort typically refers to the
eligibility levels not the amount of
spending because there isn't as
representative Stringham noted is in his
question there isn't a limit on who can
participate if you're eligible you're
eligible
um and so with respect to Medicaid it
refers to maintaining the eligibility
levels and and and sometimes also can
go ahead thank you Mr chair so is it
possible to understand
which funds are tied to Dollar spend
versus percentages of Eligibility if I
heard you correctly right some funds are
about who's enrolled in the program to
meet that minimum threshold and other
fun other funds or programs are tied to
Dollars spent so so the budget briefing
books that that we've been providing and
will continue to will provide the public
health tomorrow
um we've tried to set those up to
address that very question and address
the question of what funding sources are
in this account are there any specific
unique circumstances
um the intent of those books is to try
to hit that very question
um and and if there are specific
questions that you don't see answered in
there please let me know and and we will
get you an answer
I'll just ask again on the briefing book
where where is the Medicaid section what
page
I've gone through this several times I
just I must be blind
so
um if if we're talking about standard
Medicaid
on page 12 I see very big child care
licensing
I don't I don't see and I see the first
Black Bullet Medicaid provider
enrollment unit are my pages different
so on on page 12 if if you scroll down
about Midway it's Medicaid management I
think I'm on a different budget book
somehow
Mr chair go ahead thank you Mr chair
so I appreciate that we got these and
I'm looking at it now if there's any way
to get them the day before the
presentation so we can review them ahead
of time it's a whole lot easier than
trying to review them right they came
this morning to review them concurrently
why they're being covered
okay so uh
starting on page 27 is
um I think there was an interest when we
were here uh last budget cycle in terms
of our quality strategy and and various
activities related to
um
Service delivery and we we come up with
each year
um
10 or 11 goals
to try to improve but uh just in terms
of slide
28 is just a
a reference to the consumer guide that
people who are choosing among the three
plans can look at so Mr Lipman sure
slide 27 and 28 lots of interesting
information which lines in the
governor's budget are you justifying
I I I'm not seeing the connection
between sort of this General background
information and the decisions you're
asking division three to make
so I think
in the end right the level of spending
um you're looking for we're looking for
certain outcomes to be improved through
that spending
um I don't know that there's a
one-to-one
correlation but I think in terms of what
is the spending
um delivering for us in terms of of
quality and where do we need to improve
based on you know our program is how I
would connect this section
um to the budget
um
and so I think that that's
um I can
either continue here or go back come
back to it if we have more time if
that's your preference
you know as I mentioned at the outset
I'm I'm really kind of interested in the
spreadsheet where we look at the various
rates and what your recommendations are
and this sauce is feeling like lots of
good General background but I don't know
how to connect the general background to
your budget request I don't know which
budget requests are reasonable and which
are not I cannot tie these two documents
that may be my limitation but that's
I think the way I would connect it is
you know the two big line items of
expenditures are in 79 48 and 7 70 51
which are the the general standard
Medicaid Program and also uh the
children's health insurance program
obviously not in here because it's not
on budget is also the granted Advantage
program and we're required
um and also committed to trying to
um
deliver on certain metrics related to
the program and how for example in this
report is a discussion of our eqro which
is uh if you kind of think about it in
the construction business right
sometimes you have a clerk of the works
the the clerk of the works in the case
of the Medicaid Managed Care Program as
the eqro they come in and evaluate
whether the CMS makes the state pay for
this is to make sure that the contract
terms are being met that are in the
Managed Care contract so that would be
one example of connecting that
expenditure
um in in our contracts line to um to the
budget that you see
um that would be one I think concrete
example
um then there with respect to the
waivers where we're getting extra
opportunity to draw a federal match
where we otherwise wouldn't typically do
it we're required to do evaluation
reports have an outside evaluator that's
part of what's in this section as well
so in terms of uh the ability to draw
extra money to for substance use
disorder and to um for mental illness
and in other parts of the department uh
there are waivers where we're getting
additional ability to to fund our
program without using general funds
um so that's I guess how I would make
the connection
um and then just purely in terms of the
the color chart our areas can I tell you
how I look at it sure
I look that we got a Governor's budget
request we have specific programs lined
up we have specific line elements of of
each area with dollar amounts
to the extent that the dollar amount is
Justified the Manpower requests are
Justified it should be because that
there's some sort of a backup saying you
see this line item the reason this makes
sense is because this is what we're
doing
that that that's the connection between
the budget and the explanation that in
my view would be really helpful I I like
all of this stuff we could have done
this though before the budget was
released this is all good background
information as far as I can tell
so
um did you have a question
representative I did and you may get to
this um twice I've heard you mentioned
that the granite Advantage program is
not part of the budget
um if I recall there is some portion of
State spending involved in that I don't
remember the percentage off the top of
my head are you covering that later in
this presentation of course okay thank
you
um again that's why and when I at the
beginning of our presentation I said
here's different sections we could cover
or not cover I'm happy not to I know the
only reason I include this section is
last time we came through this committee
two years ago different composition they
asked for this information so we were
trying to be anticipatory and I
um
so okay
foreign
talk a little bit about Granite
advantage
um
if if you uh
I think one page got out of ordering but
.
this shows you from
January 1 of 19 through the estimate
that was prepared
um through State fiscal year 25
what the expenses the non-federal share
representative hoole is the the third
lying down and how we
obtain the money to fund that 10 share
is the second section of the document if
I'm understanding correctly that second
section should be in the budget
somewhere tied to line items
that's what I heard you say it's not in
the budget right the proportion that's
covered by the state needs to be in this
document somewhere to look at
um it's not by the Department's design
the way it is it's that's
the way it's been accounted for it's the
law yeah but one of my goals and I would
you be okay with it being on budget I
believe I asked
we're agnostic with respect to I mean
whatever the legislature how they wanted
it accounted for there's no reason that
that just like other you know other
agency things elsewhere these same
funding sources could be used but within
the budget so that it just appeared
there and would it be make sense to then
ask for a separate accounting unit for
that so that they could be accounted for
it separately from the standard Medicaid
if it were to be included in the budget
follow up to that question sure
so what would we need to do to make that
happen
okay I've had an epiphany over here the
vice chair has been educating me
she says that what I ought to have been
looking at is I should have been
correlating three different documents
well while we were looking at this one
we have the the governor's budget
proposal two on the handout there's two
slides in there that are particularly
relevant Pages seven and eight yes seven
and eight map into the budget book and
then instead of looking at all the
colored slides I should have slipped
over to this other unmarked document
that that happens to start with maternal
opioid misuse and model and it starts on
page one like the other four of these do
that's that's what we wanted to do right
so so
are you done
[Laughter]
we want to provide what information do
you want
I I really want to see the spreadsheet I
do I want to see the rates I want to see
what your recommendations are I want to
know what the impact is on the budget
because
we're we're going to end up doing pretty
much what the governor's budget request
is I believe you know I don't I'm not
seeing a lot of debate there but the the
real issue before us the one that we
have to really talk about and decide I
think is we what what do we want to do
with the 3.1 percent do we want to just
take what the governor's ask us or do we
want to put in the effort to figure out
if we want to make any tweaks to it I I
think that's that's the biggest decision
we've got to make and I feel like we
ought to start getting to it okay
so in terms of uh
a colored presentation if you go to the
last two pages the one that we've been
going through
um
what I
you know the the exercise that you asked
us to do is a very large exercise there
um we've started to work on it
um and but I think in terms of
um
we've given you on slide 49 a look at
calendar 2019 which is sort of
pre-covered period right and then 22 is
a more we're getting back to to normal
period in terms of expenditures in these
major groupings
um
we
so that's sort of a starting point so we
know kind of what the base is this
excludes
um Administration this is just the
services this is Services delivered in
the case of Pharmacy and DME it would
include some of the actual
Pharmaceuticals and supplies the
governor's budget in his address he that
the
3.1 percent was intended to cover
services not
other things
okay in terms of things that we pay for
under Medicaid Medicaid services
provided by providers is what the the
3.1 percent was intended for so what's
on this page a little bit more than that
but so
we had
um
and Senate Bill 86 we had done some
analysis of that bill earlier which is
the request for 145 million
um over the biennium and just to to sort
of give you what that would equate to if
you applied it across the board would be
about 11
across the board for
what's in the budget and then another
approximately four million dollars to
cover the granite Advantage component in
terms of of those State matching funds
um so this is sort of the the
if you will the base in which rates
might be applied to okay that's that's
what you have here
um I do have
um outside of this which I can hand to
you
um
I did a couple looks at it the the chair
asked me to sort of look at the Peridot
principle in terms of looking at sort of
the 80 20 perspective and so we did a
couple of cuts of that with the time
that we had available one one cut was
looking at the Professional Service
component which is the the
491 million of spending in
um in state fiscal year 22. so we're are
you on table one or table two when
you're citing that number I'm citing um
the last very last page which is
50 550 table two fifty table two
and and I see a 472 is that the number
you're talking about I'm I'm looking at
the fourth one down Professional
Services okay 491 41 788 total okay I
see that number now so so just from an
illustration standpoint I have a handout
that we was prepared over the weekend on
that in terms of trying to look at how
many codes gets you to about 80 percent
of the the spend and then
um
if I cover earlier in the presentation I
sort of talk about a philosophical
approach in terms of how to approach
rate setting which is
um you know beginning with
um
looking at how our rates where we have
an available rate to compare to Medicare
I talked about in in this presentation
um
typically
Medicaid is a percentage of Medicare uh
as opposed to 100 of it Medicare is
supposed to represent the cost of a
reasonably efficient provider to deliver
a service in Medicaid there aren't
always a matching number because of
services that we provide are not
included in the Medicaid Program are
structured differently
um and so I think the exercise on a
targeted rate increase basis is about
looking at it and sort of coming coming
around an issue so you know looking at
just how does the rate compare to
Medicare is one component of it looking
at other factors is are also necessary
to decide what you need to do when
you're talking about a targeted rate
increase you know is there an access
issue in other words are we able to
provide the services that people are
authorized to get are we able to provide
them timely
another set of issues is how do how does
our rate compare to other states how
does the providers financial status
as a group play into it how does
um
how does the workforce issues in that
sector work and what is their percentage
like for example some providers are 80
or 90 percent Medicaid so getting paid a
percentage of your cost on 80 or 90 of
your business it is very different than
if you're five percent Medicaid in terms
of how rates factor into targeting
something
so that's that's I think the the
exercise with a targeted rate increase
we need to to be going through
um and I outline that in in this this
deck there are some slides that deal
with that but the you say you outline
that outline that that sort of concept
page slides uh
42 and 43 was what I just sort of
summarized
is is you know how how rates
you know generally work Medicaid rates
as a percentage your Medicare rates are
intended to cover a fully reasonably
efficient Provider commercial rates
would sometimes also need to be used you
know they're typically two times that of
Medicare
um Physician Services are usually one
and a half times
um doesn't always hold true in all
provider types if that's true we have 13
000 codes that we pay for but as uh as
the chair noted it's there's a large
percentage that occur in a relatively uh
small number of codes
um but I I've included in the slide deck
starting at page
um 44 some examples of of this this is
not finished product work but to try to
be responsive to the the chairs so this
doc that's slide 44 this is still
historical this is this is not what
you're proposing no this is just to give
you a feel looking at it well 544 is
looking at our our FIFA service
activity only what percent of Medicare
do these service code categories uh fall
into you can see
um you know from surgery codes being 47
percent of Medicare
um you know being the low the the one at
the bottom at 188 is sort of a it's a
very small area and it's kind of
connected to supplies as opposed to
something else but just trying to give
you a flavor of what type of approach
you would take to at least as a starting
point so within Medicaid yep we we pay a
very small percentage of fee for service
right that was the whole point of the
MCO so the percentage of Medicare so if
I I am talking about the Medicaid budget
at some point yes so this is we're still
talking about Medica
our rate in which the MCO pays and our
budget is built off is built off paying
these percentages
today okay and that's why I think you're
hearing from the provided community at
large they're having difficulty meeting
that
um and
um
so so once the money gets to the MCO do
they set their own rates for what they
pay out or or or do they still maintain
some sort of uh connectivity to the
initiating fee for service calculations
they do
generally a provider doesn't typically
contract below the Medicaid rates they
typically contract for a little bit
above them because they expect that the
MCS that's a similar question or may or
or if it is I don't recognize my
question and your answer so I guess as
directly as possible the the fee
schedule that we publish is close to
what the managed care companies pay in
almost all instances on a fee for
service basis but by the time we give
them the money and they go into a
Managed Care Organization format they
are no longer paying fee for service are
they
their reimbursement typically follows
our fee schedule so an example of a
hospital okay so even though it's an MCO
it's an MCO to us but it's still largely
uh the nature of a fee for service
within their MCO within their own
internal operations is that what I'm
hearing you say
in large measure yes okay
uh representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question can we go back just
to something you said a few minutes ago
on page 43 comparing Regional State
rates can you discuss what the rates are
around us and how that could potentially
impact Workforce shortage particularly
communities that are near
um
other states thanks
it I guess what I'm getting at there is
it's very specific to very specific
Services I have in here an example of
that where
where I can show you how we might look
at it and in sort of two instances I
included in here an example with our
ambulance services and I include an
example with home Home Health Care
private duty nursing and LPN Services
where I where I showed that kind of
analysis it's it's a this is a very big
project that's gonna to do targeted
radius increases going to not be
something we do in weeks it's going to
take us months to be able to work
through it
um
but in terms of of giving you a general
sense of what the dollar figure needs to
be in in the budget I think it's sort of
a sort of push-pull here is that I think
you're going to hear from the provider
community that three percent is far
below what they see that they need
um in
um in a in a budget request I think in
part
um
this is where I think it the art of this
whole rate setting process comes is that
you know in certain certain situations
even if we're paying what other states
are paying or close to it you may hear
that it's not sufficient for
doing business in New Hampshire because
of whatever issues that they have and
and then
um even Benchmark to Medicare may not be
all that they feel that they need in
order to to survive and keep up with
what's going on inflationary wise we in
developing our recommendation I think
the what the governor included was you
know goes back to August July time frame
when the market was you know bubbling up
that rate increases were needed but I
think in the past number of months it's
really with inflation having taken off
this fall in particular that we're
seeing much larger asks than what we
included in the budget
so just to try to just
I'm just taking a practice at using your
slide 44. yes okay so a practice
oversimplification of the analysis would
be oh look we're paying 47 on surgery
codes that's probably too little given
that under the coronavirus testing codes
we're paying 75 so there's probably some
sort of
cost crisis that we're creating in those
different percentage reimbursements
that that's my simple view of this data
yes and I think that part of the
situation with our codes is prior to the
21 and 20 20 and 21 rate increase in
some instances we hadn't touched our
fees in a decade or more some two
decades so some of these is just fallen
out over time the Long Haul okay
so so now the the problem
I would have with trying to take that
simple analysis and say okay 47 is too
low 75 is too high I don't know what the
relative impact of a change in those
areas are because I don't know what the
total spend is so like if the surgery
code spend is 40x
what the
coronavirus testing code is then it
doesn't really matter that I change one
for the other because there's not enough
money there to rescue surgery codes so I
have an example that I'm prepared to
hand out that give you that level of
detail on the Professional Services it
has the has the code description this is
what you ask for me yeah it has a code
description it has the the spend on that
code
um and the dollar amount of our current
fee schedule so oh fantastic so we can
do that for the entire thing but it's
it's just something I couldn't
accomplish in a week's No no no I and
and I have to give you credit publicly
you know because I don't think people
know what I asked you to do uh once the
governor said that he thought we could
look at targeted uh Medicaid uh help uh
I I went to Mr Lipman and others and
said well what have you done so far to
look at targeted uh changes and they had
not yet started the analysis and I said
oh geez well if we're going to even look
at this could you could you could you do
an urgent crash project using sort of an
80 20 rule the 80 20 rule for those who
aren't familiar with it is if you just
if you just look at the data or the work
that would get 80 percent of the job
done typically that only takes like 20
percent of the time it's not accurate
but it gets you into the ballpark and so
what Mr lippman has done when he's
mentioned the 80 20 rule is he's just
done a down and dirt 30 hear the things
with the biggest impact that I can get
to in the least amount of time and I
appreciate you scrambling and so there's
going to be questions we may ask that
you don't have the answer for because
you just haven't had the time so I want
to thank you for your patience and and
your Indulgence I appreciate the
question somebody over here has a
question
representative Stringham you got your
mic on yeah it's on thank you a couple
of couple of areas I have questions of
what they are first under transportation
systems including ambulance and uh you
know I know the national ambulance fee
schedule is uh the biggest mess of any
Medicare fee schedule right now some
pleased to see that it's a high
percentage but what do you mean by
medical and surgical supplies in the
same groups so I think that this is a
very small category and I have an
ambulance example on slide
um
47 because our ambulance rates were very
are not good that that's I think there's
a small number of dollars in that last
category
um that's related to supplies and you
know as I think uh commodities
whereas we haven't Revisited our fee
schedule at time I think some of the
supplies in in uh
that are used by ambulances are are
probably haven't reflected how the
market has evolved in some of those
categories of uh Commodities but the the
service but the people going to the
house or going to the facility and
picking someone up and taking them
somewhere else are reflected on slide 47
where we were you know the major
categories a low of 22 percent of
Medicare to a high of 38 percent of
Medicare
the last session we we increased that to
50 percent of Medicare was what was
approved in the special session last
session to increase those rates but I
can tell you just
that I'm just this past week I had three
nursing homes reach out to us that said
you know the ambulance provider no
longer will do the what I call the chair
car services
um on a regular basis because they can't
staff it they can't afford to do it at
the rates that that we have and you know
that's been a perennial issue and if you
look around other states I think you
sounds like you have some sense of like
Massachusetts and what they've
experienced that uh
um and Maine that that ambulance
providers are having a hard time hanging
in the market here and we've seen that
more recently during some of the Surge
and not covered but just
surge because of lack hospitals have
told us they've had a hard time moving
um yeah I'm just more familiar with the
with the national uh ambulance effort to
understand costs they can redo that the
the Medicare rates but yeah not what's
going on in Mass for example
um the other two I have questions for in
here temporary codes from the dmercs uh
this is still bound 44. so
there's durable medical equipment those
are usually managed by Meridian or one
of the durable medical equipment
regional carriers
and um I don't know what a temporary
code is for them so it may have created
or it may be as you know sometimes with
with
um equipment and things that CMS signs a
temporary code until there's more
experience so
most of our population that get health
insurance except for typically two
thousand to four thousand people are
getting it through the Managed Care
Organization so of the 250 000 people
you know this is a very small percentage
for for very specific reasons that don't
go on the regular Managed Care Program
and you're right that the the DME is
managed through the mcos and their
subcarriers that you reference one of
them
um
again I think
the in terms of the time frame to put
this together the some level of detail
that I haven't been able to fully get to
okay that's
um I'm going to jump if I can one more
question in terms of the you know
there's three contracts that we have in
there that over over many years that
total about five billion dollars for the
three mcos
um
uh so I assume most of what they get
they're spent giving out to Providers uh
how how are they rewarded or compensated
is it just a straight percentage over
the top or their quality qualifiers is
there anything you can talk about on
that and how how that rolls into the
budget sure so New Hampshire approaches
its rate setting the mcos are in effect
price takers are we work with our
actuary based on experience and we say
this is what we're willing to pay and we
take into account that this variation
among the mcos and and their efficiency
we don't build it each MCO get their own
rate it's built off of it's built off
experience in different rate cells or
different categories of eligibility
the way that our state is currently
managed
approximately 89 percent
of the capitation rate goes to
delivering paying providers
there's a one and a half percent
um profit margin that's built into the
rate potential
um and then there's a two percent
premium tax that is built into the rate
that's required and then the balance
which is about eight percent varies
between
7.6 and 8.5 depending on the the
category is is for the administration of
the program
and uh
we have all the contracts are the same
there's no no difference between the
mcos we set one one contract
one rate and
um we currently have
um
risk card is in place to protect against
and over the the law has an 85 minimum
threshold with respect to spending on
the program we've actually because we've
put in a risk card or we've pushed that
up to 89 percent in terms of being spent
so that would be a follow-up so that
would be something risk court or
something like an end-stage renal
disease patient or it's it's somebody's
in a high-risk category and you expect
their expenditures to be higher is that
the idea so that we do have what we call
stop loss right that's um but we also
have a risk card which is the total
spend basically was the premium Priced
Right to begin with and during the
during the the 2019 period starting for
us in our contract beginning September
of 19. we've had protections against
underutilization leading to excess
profits for the mcos
we've built in this risk card situation
so that if there was low utilization the
state's protected from overpaying
representative erf
I thank you
so we talk about the rates
is it the Medicare the average with
regard to Medicare rate or is it another
rate is it a percentage is absolute
number and where would we find them so
we have
um a basis where you can get a site
where you can get our fee schedule it's
like 13 000 codes as I mentioned on it
um
the um the mco's typically use that as a
basis of their negotiation
with providers and so typically
um
the the average price is typically
around 101 to 102 is what they end up
paying providers almost in all
categories there's some categories where
they can negotiate better because the
market
but generally it averages about 101 to
102 percent of our fee schedule is what
they're paying
for services sometimes it's in the form
of a
a drg a fixed global payment or
not the cases it may be a shadow
foreign
but um
they generally are following the fee
schedule
so when you're increasing rates across
the board 3.1 percent what what are you
multiplying by 3.1 percent or 103.1 you
have to go ahead I'll
code times the use rate
times
um to come up with what the impact is
and that's that's a level of detail that
we have to to get to
okay and do you have a sense is is that
somewhere in here a sense of which rates
sort of the range from
furthest from right to closest to right
so we have you know in decades we've
never had that opportunity to look at a
targeted rate increase
um and I think the issues that we face
in terms of managing the the fee
schedule is a function that
that we haven't been able to do that
it's something that needs to be done
it's long long overdue and we want to
come up with a more consistent way it's
not going to be fixed in one one year I
don't I understand that or one budget
but are there obvious ones that are way
too low or obvious ones that are really
pretty close
there yes I I think I can give you some
examples of where
um in the sheet I have if I can pass it
and I'll just add what the chairman said
this is excellent to get down to this
level of understanding in the years I've
been here I've not gotten this this
depth of understanding and and I think I
think I had a question there so what
let's assume let's pretend for a moment
that we were able to come up with a
targeted fee structure change that that
the the division and the finance
committee would be behind what does that
look like are you guys getting ready to
renegotiate your MCO contracts and would
this be like an addendum to say you know
here here's what we're reimbursing
please implement this in your in your
scrub your payment structures is that
what what what what's the what's the
vehicle to get from our decisions to
actual payments to providers so we would
work with our actuary we would give them
the new fee schedule and they would look
at buy eligibility group what the impact
is based on the utilization for that
particular group like people who are in
nursing homes have a different pattern
of utilization than children and so
depending on how you move the codes
for a particular rate it's going to
impact those different rate cells
differently but every time the
legislature does sort of a one-off
increase like with the ambulance or with
maternity care the next time we do a
contract Amendment we usually been doing
one for July 1 and 1 at January so that
we're picking up both um
the budget and the uh any subsequent
session so we typically are mending the
contract two times a year we're
currently the current MCO vendors the
current procurement ends August of 24 so
we're right now planning for our next
procurement but whatever rate change the
legislature makes we'll take that back
and work with our people and their team
to come up with a a pretty precise
impact of what if you say we could get
17 million or 100 million or whatever
the number is that that we can come back
to you and say this is how it would be
spread out and we would use
so my I love the explanation but as I'm
listening to that I'm concerned that as
a division we basically only have one
shot at it ourselves that we we have to
we have to finish our work by the end of
March
and then whatever we give to the process
is still has to go through an Actuarial
review to determine what the real impact
is
would I should I be concerned that we
might make some targeted changes and we
might break something
so what if I were to in sitting in your
seats and trying to make the decision
it's sort of what what can you afford to
you knowing what what's out there what
you're going to hear right what in the
the larger budget can you afford to
invest in them we would then translate
that to the best in trying to remedy
some of these gaps between where we are
with Medicare in certain instances and
um you know I apologize for the size of
what's in front of you but this is just
the taking the Professional Services for
2022 looking at the top getting to that
80 percent
um ratio if you look at the far far
right uh the bottom column when you get
to the bottom we've hit 80 percent of
the the the the number and then
oh nice
so we would repeat this for each of the
categories so to give you some idea on
the pool of money we're talking about
this is about I'm I'm talking that we
would still try to figure out what the
governor's 3.1 percent creates in terms
of incremental funds available for
distribution and that we would be
looking at potential reallocation within
the same pool I heard you say that some
people most people nearly every people
thinks it's got to be more than 3.1
percent but at least in the first pass I
don't think we should be assuming 11
percent or any other percent other than
a direct correlation there are some
places where we actually a little bit
higher than where Medicare is currently
there's some places like in delivering a
baby where we're half of what
um where we might want to be so I think
it's a very so just just give us two
examples of each where you would make an
increase and where you might do a
decrement
so if you
um it's uh code 59400 it's about
I'd say two-thirds of the way down it's
obstetrical care wait a second wait a
second wait till we get on our fingers
on it
it's in between codes
yeah
thank you okay
so
oh yeah thank you
it's
74.7 Prince thank you okay so that's a
obstetrical care you're talking about we
know that we've seen
um in the state we're down 11
obstetrical units for and we know that
uh this challenges uh for people to get
maternity care and if you look at our
fee against the what Medicare fee for
that is
um you know we can see we're just about
half of that so so where am I seeing a
increase the recommended increase it's
not on this okay it increases here yeah
this is just this is just as is as is
yes okay so and I now understanding that
what you're comparing is Medicaid to
Medicare fee that's that's a starting
point where we can
um okay so for example the top the very
top one is the case management for that
the mental health centers provide over
the course of a month there's not a a
comparable to Medicare on that one
um that that would be appropriate
so okay so I got it I I know what the
limitation of that number is what's the
second one that you think might be a
target for increase
um
and there's more than two I'm sure I'm
just trying to get a feel for the
document
so um if you look like four from the
bottom speech therapy
um you know where Medicare is at 24.48
uh medicaids at 16 20.
um we know schools Medicaid schools that
we're trying to help kids with in the
school setting it might be a good one to
to help with we know there's a Workforce
shortage there it might be a good code
to address
um
so what is the rest of this table
showings you go across
so it's just orienting there the top
does the procedure code AS defined then
a description the description sometimes
not the best but that's what's in the
system then we have the Medicaid fee the
current fee schedule as it consists
today
Medicare fees as they exist today the
then there's uh two columns standard and
Grant GA hcp stands for granted
Advantage Healthcare program under the
MCM program meaning the Managed Care
organizations that's the spending that
occurs for that code in in managed care
and then to the total span for 2022 in
that yes okay and then for
um there's a fee some FIFA service
population particularly you know we
talked about in and out Medicaid earlier
that
a lot of people who use the in and out
medicator
often people that have are
using the mental health center so you
see a good amount of FIFA service
in that category and then it's totaled
across the across the way and then to
the final cumulative percentage that
that one code represents almost 12
percent of our entire spend in that
and these are all these are all
Professional Services these are all
Professional Services the top to get to
80 percent
um and so this should be repeated of all
the categories and um
and then you know I think that uh
again just comparing it to Medicare and
then comparing it to other states
sometimes isn't enough you have to take
it further
more specifically regard to all the ones
that are blank underneath Medicaid yeah
Medicare rather what do you compare them
to so that's where often looking at
other State Medicaid programs would make
sense okay so so when you said we ought
to look at all the categories here
referring to the categories listed on
page 41 of the colored handout
were professional as a third one down
and you got inpatient Hospital
outpatient facility
Pharmacy Dental Nursing Facility are
those the other categories that you
would do something similar if time
permitted
um the very last page would be would tie
to this slide 50 would be
we looked at
that one category Professional Services
we would look at
all of these and we might choose to
break it down different than here but I
just again trying to get something
together for you this is a grouping that
okay and you took a you took a big
number yep
and waiver services at 5 18 that's a
bigger number but you didn't pick it
what's unique about waiver services that
it didn't handle this
um if I again if I had another 24 hours
we might have been able to pull together
I do have waiver Services
um but I haven't got to the level of
putting in other comparators they just
have the pure 80 percent if you want
let me just finish this and then we'll
come okay so so just just touch the two
that you would indicate this is the hard
one it's always easy to talk about the
potential increases what do you see any
Bill payers
so this
this gets to sort of the art of some
things right that
um to decrease a fee in Medicaid is
sometimes a a process that you have to
do go through and get approvals the way
I would generally approach this is the
ones that are above or
or too high at this point I would just
leave them alone and let time take care
of them would be one approach if we
really felt there was a lot of money it
might be worth going through the process
so let's do the first thing tell me two
foreign
I think it's h
63 level right because where it is
um you know we're at 112 29 on that fee
what's the name of this service
it is it's got a sort of a cryptic
Family
Psychological treatment with a patient
50 minutes
but here again this might be a good
example where you hear with the mental
health provider shortage you wouldn't
necessarily want to cut the rate because
you know take into account
um
okay so so without giving us a second
one I think you just teed up a good
division three conversation and and and
and what
it feels to me
is that while this is a long overdue
process of coming back and looking at
the targeting of rates
that the amount of time available is
extremely limited and that if we were to
rush this project we would probably be
as likely to break something
as we would be to fix something or in
the best case we might break something
in your actuarials will say no and it
won't actually go into effect and we'll
have just wasted our time and analyzing
it that that's that's sort of what I
feel is our situation is that is that
close to your perception I would take
what you say but add to the to it I
think ultimately as saying our chairs is
that it's there definitely is I think a
clamor
um out there and evidence of of gaps in
Service delivery
that suggests that it
a dollar amount that you can fit into
the entire budget that we would go to
work with utilizing these type of
criteria and report to you on a regular
basis would be how we get to a point
that I think you'd be comfortable with
okay I think I'd left you hanging
representative Stringham yeah thanks
um
um you know you talk about a percentage
of Medicare you know the Medicare fee
schedules change every year sometimes
the change within individual codes based
on a changing methodology are pretty
dramatic
um and I I I think maybe some of the
numbers I'm seeing here there's been
major revisions in the evaluation and
maintenance management codes e m codes
that have actually brought down the
Medicare rates a bit and when you apply
a 3.1 percent increase
um or or whatever the number is now are
you looking at what Medicare has done
are you pay it as a percentage of
Medicare are you just raising it three
point one percent based on what Medicaid
was last year or most recent numbers
that's the first question I had so
um I'll answer two parts the the first
part is in Prior rate increases we were
told by legislation
apply 3.1 to everything and don't don't
deviate okay what we're we're suggesting
is it's
Beyond time where we have to to look at
these types of factors that I outline in
my slide deck here to just to use the
money in a way that's going to have the
biggest impact whatever that
appropriation ends up being and Medicare
alone as you're right in certain
categories things change that's why I
don't think it's a one-factor analysis I
think it's a starting point
thank you
representative just to restart what you
said in terms that makes sense to me
you would ask us to allocate some amount
of money whatever like we could take the
3.1 figure whether that comes out to or
more or less whatever and ask you to go
about resetting rates where you feel
they would give us the biggest impact in
providing services to people in the
state of New Hampshire exactly yeah and
and I I just want to point out and I
think everybody in the room knows it I
mean it's it's fundamentally different
than how things have historically in
recent years been done where we've had a
footnote that provided a five percent to
this party or legislation you know
through the past biennium but you know
what what we're proposing you know is do
does the state consider a a policy that
really takes the numbers into account
and looks at the market rates and bases
that those changes on objective
informational that's quantifiable that's
reliable and and and that that will make
some people uncomfortable and and we're
proposing the concept we're you know
we're not endorsing it necessarily but
we're proposing that as a concept and
and what Henry and his team have done to
put that kind of kind of visual together
to show you what that would look like
um you know we're just putting that out
there and um to see whether that would
be considered or not
so
um did you have follow-up
I'm sorry well I got no I didn't like to
follow but I guess I would just say that
that sort of addresses your concern that
we wouldn't be breaking anything we'd be
saying take these funds and you apply
them the best way possible and I
actually like that approach compared to
just saying up 3.1 right I'm I'm liking
it I'm just Expo I'm about to explore it
a little further okay
I'm sorry who did
he's not here
[Laughter]
okay
trailing representative Hole chairling
uh all right
so
you've given us Professional Services
and you've only given us 80 percent the
top the the 80 the 80 that spends the
money okay
this is a list as I eyeball it it feels
like it's about 50 line items 60 line
items
it's a hundred wow I think it's like 91
maybe okay so
just on this one sheet without taking
into hospital inpatient outpatient on
the other categories just on this
Professional Services area
how many of these do you think are in
crisis situation or near broken
to where
it's really in the best interest of the
citizens of the state to do a plus up
above the 3.1 percent base all of them
two of them
so I I
look at it more
I know you're asking me to give you an
answer that's specific to to code level
I think
I don't have all the use rates numbers
in my head to say this it may be for
example in in mental health there's two
codes out of all of them that really are
the difference in terms of what we're
trying to do I
I'm I'm I would as much as I want to
give you an answer that you're asking I
don't have that today
um I can get that answer for you
ultimately it's just not something that
can be done in the time frame that we
had to so I don't have ultimately on my
calendar how many days do you need to
to
I think that we need
um
a period that go extends to do the full
job
if you're asking us to do the full job
it's it's mine eighty percent of the job
category here
person
um who does rates as a specialty and
they have
other day-to-day activities in terms of
um as representative Earth knows to to
do pro share and M quip and all those
other things so so we're out of this
budget cycle no no no no no this is I'm
asking him I think the point is to for
us
to decide to give him a supplement yeah
I know I hear that but I don't know that
we could give him a supplement and not
want to hear back what are you going to
do with it why I would you come to
fiscal oh
I don't know it feels to me like public
transparency when we're setting uh some
special rates that we ought to at least
in you know open that up and subject to
a more public property we depend on them
to do all these waivers and all this
stuff into independently of us I'm
listening so you you think you think
you'd be comfortable absolutely we're
just
representative would you would you give
them a pot of money to allocate how they
saw fit crisis I'm not going to answer
that I am going to say that they're the
experts on this and to some extent we
can't be micromanaging every single line
item
on this and however we agree 100 Pages
we agree but but that's not really the
issue that we have to deal with I think
we we should should we be prepared to
talk to see if there's some amount of
money we want to give them to let them
allocate it without them coming back and
tell us and how they're going to do it
I think that's something we need to
discuss yeah so I'm trying to do that
representative Waller yes sir at this
point we don't even know if we're going
to have an increase
in Revenue
they're so slow that what's going to
come down to is okay traditionally HHS
gets 51.52 percent of the of the budget
what do we have for a new
Revenue how many is it is it an increase
if it's an increase maybe they get 52
percent of it or whatever the normal
thing is that's about all we can do
everybody is putting it to us and giving
us everything late we still don't have
hb2 we still don't have the revenue
estimates
if if we're going to make a deadline
it's not going to be going line by line
on any of this stuff it's almost going
to be down to
you're going to get 52 percent of the
increase or whatever the whatever the
amount is come back to us with a plan
and if you don't have the plan just give
us something rough because everybody is
sticking it to us by giving us
everything late
I hear you are there other comments
so
how would we do
look I'm sorry
oh represent an order I didn't see you
go ahead that's I'm I was a little slow
on the draw
um yeah I think we need to take a little
more time
and and I would agree with
representative Weiler that
we can't expect them to come up with the
numbers that quickly so I think we need
to just this is our first day with them
so
you need to give them a chance to digest
what we need and what they can give us
in a time frame
so I think we've heard them say it's
going to take them months and and I I
think I've heard the idea that seems the
most rational to me is that we leave a
3.1 percent blanket alone that's the
governor's proposal we leave that alone
but that we consider
an additional
allocation of Medicaid related money to
ask the department to go in and help
mitigate some of the worst aspects of
our rates as they exist now I I think
that's where we're at and if we're there
I'm just curious because I haven't
thought of it how would we decide how
much money that might be I guess we have
to wait for you know what you're you're
talking about we don't we don't know
what we don't know
okay so at some point we'll have to
figure out what a a bucket would look
like and how to fill it how big who
else's questions represent uh Stringham
I you know I just think a related thing
that they've hinted on before is that
the possibility that some fee schedules
access issues could be
um
could be such that they may need to
think about whether the fee schedule
should be consistent if somebody is only
doing 20 percent or less of Medicaid
versus uh 50 or more and
um and uh you know such that the the
um the provider can't can't survive at
the uh 20 for provider could survive in
a 50 or an 80 percent provider uh might
not so uh there's plenty of avenues for
uh for HHS to walk with us even Beyond
uh
um jiggling all the individual rates I
think they probably are going to start
where they see dramatic access issues in
one form or another so I'm I'm tracking
what you're saying I'm agreeing with
what you're saying and I'm on page 43 of
the colored handout where they've listed
their rate setting approach to targeted
rate increase the third one is access
assess access issues to Providers what
you're saying I think is amplifies that
step by talking about those critical
access issues the ones where we we may
be near uh I hate using the word
collapse too often but where we have a
real problem with access
and a representative hole thank you kind
of a little bit of the tangent can I can
I do a time check I just it it's 1206
we're supposed to get back here at one
uh I want to logically wrap up where
we're at so we can go take a break and
if we if people want to caucus also
before we come back at one I want to
leave some time for that so so let's
just take a few minutes if we can go go
ahead sure so
um I've heard not sure if it's true or
not that within the counseling domain
there's a large number of no-show type
appointments
um can you speak if if that is the case
can you speak to it and then what do we
do relative to the rate schedule and
reimbursements etc for missed
appointments
it's a good issue I don't have a direct
answer to counseling but the point that
you're making was made in the dental
situation because
um it's very expensive for a dentist to
have an unfilled uh chair and part of
the design of that benefit includes Care
Management and transportation to make
sure that they get there I think in
terms of counseling
um that's a pretty broad one but I think
in some instances that's what that
number one
um on that list of Professional Services
that Community Mental Health Centers
provide is that sort of care
coordination and Care Management it's
for some populations it's really
important to to get it there and
um and there's not a lot of Leverage if
someone misses an appointment you want
to charge them for it if they have no
money to to begin with it's
it's a difficult thing so it's really
and we're having a lot of good talk but
I wonder if our hands are going to be
forced on us a little bit because of the
federal court order talking about the
warehousing in the ER and the fixing it
I emailed it to to folks this morning I
I we haven't gotten an assessment of
what that Federal order is going to mean
but I I just in the back of my mind I'm
wondering if uh some of these decisions
might be forced upon US Representative
Irfan representative walner
represent Wallner
um I just wondered if we're going to
have a chance to uh hear from some of
the providers about
the rate situation
I think there are some actually here yes
I I had I had tried to get to this part
of the conversation earlier this morning
so so that there would be time uh and
where we're at is
um we we need to take a break uh we're
going to come back at one o'clock uh for
HB uh 527 that is actually going to be I
think an ongoing discussion about
targeting rates overall with the 527
issue considered specifically and then
we have at least one or two groups that
wanted to speak to us uh could you raise
your hand if you think you want to speak
to us okay now now now let's do it again
but only one group if you're in a group
just one hand goes up per group one two
three I see three groups want to talk to
us
is there there's not a fourth okay so
um
can any of you do it in three minutes or
less
okay I got one person who can do it in
three minutes or less come on come on up
it's the woman in the back
thank you so much and we'll see you guys
at one again probably all right all
right no no the woman raised her hand
first though so I I don't know her name
and I I I'm sorry I'm assuming your
you you raised your hand send somebody
up
okay come on up if you think you need
three minutes sir
you you
I don't know your name I'm so sorry I
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
my name is Brendan Williams I'm the
president CEO of the New Hampshire
Healthcare Association we represent a
long-term care facilities throughout the
state Assisted Living uh to some extent
but predominantly nursing homes as well
as the Cedar Crest Center for children
with disabilities uh I'm giving you
handouts that sort of illustrate where
we're at right now uh obviously the
pandemic has hit the nursing home sector
uh particularly hard we've seen sort of
what we call the the great resignation
in terms of the workforce realignment
that has occurred and that's a
realignment that's affected all health
care providers in our state but if it
has been particularly impactful to
nursing homes we currently have the
nation's fourth worst Staffing shortage
for nursing home care and the
consequence of that is that facilities
are turning away people who might
otherwise so for example be discharged
from hospitals
as of today the Hillsborough County
Nursing Home has a wait list of 138
prospective residents that's a story
we're seeing throughout the state where
we have beds units and wings that are
offline and unavailable for use because
responsible facilities will not admit
residents where they're not able to
provide quality Care in looking at the
examples of some other states which I
provide to you there have been
significant rate increases it's been a
bipartisan issue Republican legislatures
throughout the country have bestowed
rate increases of as high as 23 percent
in the last year
we think that something substantial is
going to be required here in New
Hampshire a rate increase on the order
of 15 percent because we cannot continue
to utilize staffing agencies
at an extraordinary cost in order to
Simply provide care to our existing
residents I include for you an invoice
from a small Catholic non-profit
facility member of ours that serves just
nuns 95 percent Medicaid occupancy and
when they're paying 43 dollars an hour
for the services of a licensed nursing
assistant to a staffing agency when the
Hillsborough County nursing home is
paying over 70 dollars an hour in some
instances
for the services of an LNA when
Rockingham County Nursing Home Mr
chairman in your county is offering 17
an hour no less for an LNA an eight
thousand dollar signing bonuses and is
still overrun with staffing agency
utilization we need the resources to be
able to invest in our Workforce and I
think those resources exist within our
state budget and so we will look forward
to having an ongoing dialogue with this
committee and very much appreciate your
time so Mr Williams will you take a
question I will certainly all right so I
I you don't know how strongly I am glad
that you've come forward I've looked at
your four documents quickly I I don't
see one of them that says what you're
asking for though I I've heard you say
you you want 15 percent more but I'm not
seeing a specific rate increase document
and I can provide that to you Mr
chairman the state cost would be on the
order of 35 million dollars over two
years obviously matched by the federal
government I think it would be best to
do it up front I know that what the
governor had proposed is to spread it
out over two years I know that that's
been the custom with legislative
Appropriations but the need is immediate
right now facilities I don't know how
facilities are going to survive until
July 1st quite apart from after July 1st
if the rate increase is inadequate so I
can certainly get you some more
granularity when it comes to details you
want Mr chairman I I appreciate that I
think the granularity will help we don't
we don't have a lot of time for us to
talk about it and so the closest we can
get to something that'll look like a
snapshot of the answer the the better
you know very happy to provide that to
you Mr chairman questions questions
representative
thank you for taking our questions
so can you explain
how
increasing rates is going to increase
the number of
nurses
well we have some structural problems in
our state that are sort of Beyond three
minutes that I'm allocated here
obviously housing is a huge issue and uh
you know commendably this legislature
and the governor of invested resources
there
to to conjure up a Workforce through
Medicaid rate increases when that
Workforce doesn't presently exist I
think to whatever degree we can reward
our existing workers more uh that that's
going to be able to stabilize the
workforce and hopefully draw more people
into the workforce
so I understand that argument but it
seems right now that things are so out
of balance that all is going to happen
is the agencies will just increase what
they're going to pay to the nurses and
you're going to have this
problem that just it gets worse and
worse as opposed to getting better as
you're proposing
I'm concerned about that uh
representative but I have seen an
examples of some other states decreasing
agency utilization if we look at
Massachusetts for example our staffing
shortage is about six times worse than
theirs because they have put significant
resources into stabilizing the nursing
home Workforce so I'm confident that
based on the examples of other states
including those in New England that we
this is great a little more than three
minutes but representative norgren do
you have
uh just just a question and a comment I
think
the hospitals are seeing similar issues
um and and I think the combination of
the pandemic and nurses retiring early
just because they want to get out
um it's probably impacted you the same
as the hospitals around the state it has
representative norgren and we are
working in concert with the hospitals
and also uh Home Care Advocates to try
to look at this situation holistically
because it is an interdependent system
and you're absolutely right about that
all right any other questions
representative Waller Stringham anyone
okay Mooney
Weiler okay so
um I have about 12 18 do you have any
final words of wisdom for us Mr Williams
no thank you Mr chairman all right uh
with that I'm going to put us into
recess at one o'clock and we'll come
back and uh we'll talk about HP 527 but
we'll continue very much along this very
same Dynamic all right thank you
foreign
because
okay so let's open this version
okay it's um past one o'clock uh we're
gonna come out of recess
um on division three but uh we're going
to open
if you are here
specifically to talk about 527
raise your hand please
okay are you are you two one group or
are you like two people
okay is there another group other than
you two that want to talk specifically
on 527
right
okay so what my intent here
is because you're here specifically to
talk about 527 is to hear you two
I'd like to keep it short because I want
to go back into the broader context of
the discussion we were having this
morning about you know we have endless
requirements for additional money and
limited resources and we're trying to
figure out how to how to balance it all
oh
oh I'm sorry I thought you were like
yeah
okay uh let's have you stand by then
go ahead
okay so I'm gonna recess uh HP 527
um and we'll we'll reconvene it later
today
or am I supposed to say a time later
today all right so when we last were
here we I think we're ready for Gina
Haskin Haskins
come on up we can pull up another chair
hold on a second represent I'm sorry I'm
just a little confused as to what just
happened we're not going to be working
on 527 right now not for now okay and we
are going to go back to the conversation
we had prior to lunch right gotcha thank
you right right and so so I'm pursuing
the general strategy of trying to
understand overall all of the demands
for money because one of the things that
has happened to us over the years is
that we have individual interest groups
come to us making an excellent case that
they need more money so we've slapped
Band-Aids on a lot of things and I think
over time
we may have a requirement to figure out
how to clean it all out and sort of a
system review sort of way so I want to
come back to 527 but I'd still like to
set the context
a presentation
of information we received before lunch
and I think what we're going to hear now
this is Medicaid funded
but it is not in
the Medicaid budget it's in the adult
and elderly section so I would like
someone to direct us to those correct
pages
in the budget okay so so can you do that
Gina or should we ask Mr White to stick
my name is Gina balkus and I'm the CEO
at the Home Care hospice and palliative
care Alliance of New Hampshire and our
advocacy affiliate the granite state
home health and hospice Association and
I just like to ask my colleagues to
introduce themselves
I'm Kathy slack from Bayada Home Health
I'm Amy Moore from Essentia Care
Alliance
and we're going to talk today about two
programs one that's in elderly and Adult
Services on page 934 of the budget which
is also where you're funding for
residential care facilities Falls so I
think that's the connection
and then we're also going to talk about
Medicaid private duty nursing services
a presentation for you for your
reference and all I have um
eight slides that I'll go through really
quickly can answer questions when you
give us a page number is that a PDF page
number or the actual page number it's
the slide of the page on the oh wait uh
the PDF you talk about the budget
she said 9 34 and I think I'm seeing
where it says grants for Social Services
Program No it should be nursing services
yes that's the page
uh some of it is yes some of it is
County
yes a lot of it is County
so I'll start out with the presentation
that was handed out to you uh on page
two after the title so the choices for
Independence program for those of you
who I know many of you are aware of it
but I'm gonna just explain it really
quickly this is a Medicaid waiver
program for people who are low income
and eligible to be in a nursing home
but they live at home and they get
long-term services and support
the services are provided by a range of
providers from small privately owned
home care agencies to large social
service agencies like accentria that Amy
runs to traditional visiting nurses
associations to large
local offices of national companies and
the issue that we have and this gets
directly to the issue of reimbursement
rates from the Department of Health and
Human Services is that the rates do not
allow the agencies to pay competitive
wages and recruit and retain workers
and that is impacting access to care we
simply cannot provide enough Services
based on the for what the people need
and I I've been
um lobbying for 35 years on Healthcare
issues and 12 now on home care and I
don't think I've ever seen it this bad
as bad as it is now
so the the the danger really is that
agencies like accentria and Waypoint and
others are in danger of having to give
up CFI to just stop serving agent
patients because we can't deliver the
services so we'd like the the rates to
be to go to a specific level it's not a
percentage it's a level based on a rate
analysis that we've done internally much
like Mr Lipman has done on his end and
that is to make it comparable to New
Hampshire's title 3B and 20 program and
the median private Market rates and
average or a percentage of Medicare
costs so before I go on just real
quickly the before you go on I I want I
need to make sure that our newest
members the division three are in tune
with what we're talking about okay
the the
choices for Independence program is was
initially set up as I understand it back
in the days when we decided that we
wanted to put into place a bed
moratorium in our Nursing Home Centers
and that because we imposed a limit in
our Nursing Home Centers we needed other
options to keep people who might
otherwise want to go to a nursing home
but would have preferred to stay home
anyways so this is a program that helps
the state keep the population of the
nursing homes down while doing a great
service to the the clients themselves
because most people would prefer to stay
at home anyways but so so that's really
when the CFI program took off and became
a fundamental component of our long-term
nursing strategy is that right I'm not
sure of the timing but I do but your
explanation of that CFI is for people
who who prefer to be at home is and that
it does it does work it coexists with
nursing home and residential care it's
it's a coexisting service and that if
we're cold-blooded money people we would
look at CFI as a grossly or not grossly
but a significantly reduced cost to the
taxpayer it may be on the order of an
eighth of the cost I have some of that
in this slide yes absolutely it's the
lowest cost option I believe so this is
a smart program that people want that
does the state some good and the
taxpayers benefit you're doing my
presentation for me I I just I'm just
trying I'm just trying to make sure I
got it you've got it all right so one of
the issues um and on PA the next slide
what you'll see is that this is a slide
from the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute report that they did this
summer and I would encourage you to go
on to nhfpi.org and read this report
it's excellent but this is just a really
telling slide
part of the problem that that why you
have providers like me coming forward
and asking for money for specific
Services is because the CFI program has
been underfunded for years and
what you see here is a chart that shows
that starting in 2011 if the state had
had just every year increased the amount
of money in the funds for the choices
for Independence program
by the Medicare Market Basket home Home
Health Market Basket index which is
basically a federally
determined inflation factor which
averages about two and a half percent a
year
um
if the state had had done that starting
in 2011 it would be the funding in the
program would be at the blue line but
instead it's at the green line so what
you have is a structural deficit within
the choices for Independence program and
so choices for Independence is larger
than just home care services as I
mentioned as you'll hear later
residential care facilities are part of
the choices for Independence program but
Meals on Wheels Adult Day programs those
are all part of CFI I'm here today to
talk about the home home based Home
Health based program any questions so
far
foreign
the next slide what we have here is
these are the um four services that are
provided Within by Home Health agencies
the first one is Homemakers and I've
showed you the current rate these are
people who will come in to the home and
do
housekeeping change sheets do grocery
shopping prepare some meals in advance
maybe do the grocery shopping for the
client and
um the the state pays that um the
agencies in 15-minute increments and for
Homemakers it's five dollars and forty
cents per unit
um I might I'm going to ask I'm going to
ask you a time out here because because
basically we can read this okay and I
want to I want to map this slide to the
budget so exactly which line number okay
would this go to if we were to agree
to line 506.
so that's called home support waiver
services on page 934 yes line 506 and
all the others would go online just to
make sure I'm still tracking yep then FY
22 that was listed at
63.344 million dollars is are we on the
same line so I don't have that page
anymore but it sounds about Mr White
I'm just I just want to make sure that
we're all talking the same thing
and I want to point out that line 506 I
call that the CFI kitchen sink line
kitchen sink line because it's got it
has personal care services in it which
is the bulk of it but that's also
includes Meals on Wheels Adult Day Care
Emergency responder programs uh you know
ramps and accommodations in homes so
this line and the governor's budget
if we're talking about the same line
goes from 22 where it was 63.3 Million
to 92.6 million so the governor's budget
appears to be adding nearly 30 million
dollars approximately you know 28 29
above the 22 level well but if you look
at lines 529 and 505 the the governor's
budget zeros out those lines
and in I believe from what I've been
told combines it all into line 506.
and my understanding from talking with
Folks at the department is the reason
they have done that is because when the
department needs to transfer funds
between these lines they have to go to
fiscal and it's an administrative burden
for them to do that I will tell you that
fiscal Community I will tell you that
um
that 529 was added in at the request of
my Association back in 1997. so we took
that 19 million or so we took 21 million
and collapsed it and we're still almost
30 million ahead so the governor's
budget still has like a 9 million
increase
um so so that's that's still over 10
it appears to be so you would need to
ask the department based on I believe
that's part of that's their prioritized
needs budget okay so I'm just trying to
understand your request you got a bunch
of 11 33 18 50 23 the governor's
budget's already 10 at least 10 percent
above that I think
above the past
and so
your request is a smaller ask than what
this your page four seems to indicate it
it may in fact be and it could be
included in the budget except to keep in
mind I'm only here talking about Home
Health Services not the broader one oh
okay not all of CFI uh I the department
would really have to be the one okay
represent a whole and then represent
Waller thank you to page four of your
handout right at the six dollars I'm
just looking at the Homemakers yes
twenty four dollars that's the rate paid
by the state to the agency
can you help me understand how that then
translates to roughly the hourly rate
for the
the Homemaker or the person who's being
hired is that is that a third lower
where are we so first of all I just want
to clarify the current rate is 21.60 per
hour the proposed rate the proposed rate
is 24 which would be equivalent to what
the state pays in the title 20 and 3B
program right I'm trying to get let's
take the 2160. what does that translate
into an hourly rate roughly on average I
can speak to the like one down the
personal care 2248 which is similar to
Homemaker so the the issue is that
somebody can be approved right for X
number of hours and that's when that
person is in the home it doesn't cover a
supervision workers comp training
support payroll all of the things
mileage that go along with that and
that's our struggle so for like pcsps
right now
um it's like 13 an hour
that's what I'm trying to get to right
in in typical Consulting and temporary
labor right it's a minimum of a 28 and
potentially as high as a 40 right
on top of the actual hourly rate that
translates to the agency rate and I just
didn't know whether you're held true or
those numbers were out of whack because
this is because of the shortage of
people yeah
um
I think that you know it I don't think
it's out of whack because of the
shortage of people as I said I've been
here for 12 years asking for rate
increases in these areas and the problem
has always been the same the
reimbursement rates are simply not
enough to cover the full cost of care
there's more pressure now though because
while agencies like Accenture are paying
personal care providers 13 an hour you
know you can go work and well you said
you had a client uh an employee that
last week that yeah so four clients left
to go I mean everyone's our competition
my daughter is 15 and she makes more
babysitting next door and she does
nothing
um so that's really our issue is
everyone's a competition one thing
that's come up that I've talked about is
that we say well well if we raise like
right the pay are there do we have the
workers and during the arpa stapins that
we've been doing I've been tracking that
data and because we're able to pay these
stipends are a little bit more right
we're like we're bringing them up to
like 15 16 an hour with this
problem is they're going to fall off
right it's one-time funding but we've
tracked that we've been able to deliver
like 20 more services because they can
actually make ends meet
so represent Walnut do you still have a
question
okay so
um
all right representative
um the uh it looks to me like this
budget that's in here may take into
account increased payment per service
but it also may take into account
increased number of services
so so you could have a 10 increase all
due to increased volume or all due to
increased and I think that I think
that's a really good point represents
drink them and I think you need to talk
with the Department about that my
understanding is that the money that's
in the budget is
a rate increase and a caseload increase
but I will I think it's important for
you to look at the the Department's
dashboard
um one would expect that there would be
a caseload increase because of the
demographics of the State of New
Hampshire but when I've looked at the
dashboard for fiscal and you look at the
line for CFI it actually has been pretty
stable for the past almost two years
which is surprising
so um there may and and this is this is
a nuance
if you're a new CFI client that's been
determined to be eligible
you're not getting any services
there's nobody available to provide
those services so so Mr Ripple I'm gonna
I'm gonna ask her I'm going to make a
request of you and Mr White uh I I think
we've identified the line we're looking
at line 506 on page 934 there's an
increase already in FY 24
and we don't know what supports that
increase at this point we don't know
what rate Factor was used we don't know
what utilization Factor was was
considered and so as a result we don't
know how to evaluate this proposal in
front of us we don't know if this is
already in the budget or if we need a
little bit more or a lot more
go ahead Mr Roy do you want to speak
grab that microphone
sure so on March 7th um the division
long term supports and services we'll be
presenting their budget to the committee
um
the numbers that you're seeing that are
in front of you those are the projected
increase utilization the the additional
three percent that was referred to that
will be included in an hb2 provision the
final language which is yet available so
when you say three percent you mean 3.1
percent because somewhere else we you
talked about three percent is just being
like a supply and inflation adjustment
yeah the the 3.1 percent correct yes
okay and I need them to be called
something different so I know which one
we're talking about so
I just want to point out that the other
service
on this um so before you get going I'm
going to ask representative walner to
ask and ask her a question oh well I'm
not gonna make a question I'm not asking
a question I can make a statement I
think what we have here is sort of the
cart before the horse if because what we
have is we have a presentation about a
specific specific service that is
embedded into a line that we don't have
enough information at this point to
really understand that line and we won't
until March 7th is my understanding
so so we agree that's why I asked the
question so that when we do hear it we
we get the context necessary to
understand the requests yeah I think it
would be much more helpful if we have I
mean I
complete this complete this one today
but if we have further ones that really
relate more to the March 7th information
it seems like it would be better to have
it at that point than to be skipping all
around like this
you're not wrong the good news is that
we we now have an opportunity to have
the department do the homework so that
we have it on March 7th and we got to be
done by the end of March no matter what
the clock is ticking so uh do you I just
want to point out that the other the
other services on this page are in would
normally be in class line 529 but
they've been zeroed out and I would just
say for the sake of transparency we
would prefer they stay in 529 and not be
all combined I think that it gives
um the public more understanding if it's
not zeroed out
um
that's that's our opinion that's an
excellent point Thank you so I just I'm
gonna I know that you have a lot of
other things to do I'm going to quickly
go through the next page and you can
read this for yourself this shows what
what based on the the requests we've had
which is to match the title 20 and 3B
rates and to get closer to the median
private pay rates
um the current the current um value of
in fiscal year 22 the department
authorized
73.6 million dollars in home health
services this was the need
that's what they authorized for care I
can't tell you what the budget was
because I don't have the budget broken
down by service line the department
would have to share that with you all we
can see is that big line of 66 million
in class 506 but that has other services
in it
what they actually paid out was 48.9
million dollars for you an average
service utilization rate of 66.42 but
for some services like personal care
it's you know it's like 50 percent on
page eight where it says private duty
nursing would that have typically been
line 505 no it's a different page
altogether
so we're going to go into different
programs so I just want to show you that
what we're asking for in order to
stabilize the program and then grow the
program is seven and a half million in
fiscal year 24 and 9.3 million in fiscal
year 25 in general funds so when you
talked about with Mr lippman before
about giving the department the
opportunity to take funds and to Target
it to the neediest areas I totally
support that as opposed to an
across-the-board rate increase the key
thing is how much you give them
how much you give them to do what they
need to do to get to programs like this
that need services
um on the um and I think the next page
uh representative Edwards page six you
know
um what would it cost so it's about on
average the annual spend for the state
on a CFI client is about twenty thousand
dollars for a nursing facility patient
it's about eighty one thousand dollars
um if all those and there's about 3 600
people in CFI in fiscal year 22. if you
took those 3 600 people and put them all
in a nursing home it would cost you 200
200 million dollars more than you're
so next slide different program all
together different program all together
New Hampshire can we skip to slide 10
uniform home health aid rates yes is is
that on page 934 in one of those line
items or is that on a total Different
Page
so it
part of it is and part of it isn't how's
that for an answer
so this compares the rates between Title
20 and 3B which is mostly federal funds
the CFI program which is on page 934 the
Medicaid State plan which is on page 922
divided among MCO and provider payments
so it's all but this is the same service
home health aide service in three
different state programs and you can see
the three different state the
reimbursement levels and the irony is
the one that's the most acute is the one
is is in the Medicaid State Plan
services
and it gets paid the least
they should all be brought up to six
eight dollars per 50 minute unit or 32
you know for a total of thirty two
so if we if we did that second column
current CFI rate then are we on line 505
mid-level care expenses
no we would be online uh it would be in
five line 529 but now it's in the the
but I have included the rate increase
for CFI in my request of 7.2 million and
9.5 million what I haven't included is
the request for the Medicaid State Plan
service because I don't have the data to
back that up okay so I'm going to invite
you back on March 7th I I I think you've
given us a nice presentation there's
something for us to look at you've
pointed at us the the budget what what
what what 30 seconds do you have to
close so the 36 seconds I have is on a
program that is in line not on page 922
which you talked about earlier today
with Mr Lipman and he actually used this
case as an example in in one of his uh
targeted case uh requests
um service requests so Medicaid private
duty nursing is intensive care in the
home provided only by nurses for for
mostly children
and some adults who are on trachs vents
they might have ALS Kathy's they're on
heart issues
there's a whole host of medical issues
that often are dealt with in the
hospital but because they're able to be
brought home
same sort of savings that we would have
for those children to be at home to meet
their developmental stages that they
wouldn't make at the hospital we just
had a little girl graduate into services
and started kindergarten without a nurse
and that was after a couple of years of
intense support so she was able to meet
those milestones at home
so you can look at this on your own on
page eight we show you what the current
rates are we show you what the requested
rate increase it's a forty percent rate
increase
I don't know what else to tell you this
is what it's going to take to hire the
nurses to get to get into these homes to
take care of these kids and these adults
so do the nurses exist we keep running
into this I mean which is the chicken
and which is the egg we've got more
money do we have more people it's a very
difficult measure however we we have
maintained for about the last two years
we haven't grown we haven't decreased
we've gained clients we've lost clients
we've lost more nurses than we've lost
clients and when we hire a new nurse in
the expectation is that they're getting
Mass rates and the only way to hire them
is to hire them at more than more being
reimbursed it's we're chasing our Tails
trying to help these families so if we
get more people that are likely to be
and if you
if you have our exit interviews a lot of
people are just going over the line into
Massachusetts to work okay keep them
here right yeah I think the other thing
you need to know and this is just the
reality of the pandemic I mean we are
robbing Peter to payroll Paul there's no
there's no denying that
um there are Hospital nurses who are
burnt out
they want to go somewhere else this is a
viable option for them but they expect
Hospital wages and Hospital benefits and
those big bonuses all you have to do is
go on to indeed and search for nurses
and you'll see what nurses are getting
paid all right thank you
so
um I think the one thing that I would
ask you to consider and I know you're
the finance committee just remember the
reason I put all these pictures in here
too is there are real people on the
other end there are people who are not
getting the services they need the
clients that Kathy's agency serves
across the state they're getting 47
percent of their authorized Services 47
if they're lucky then I mentioned we
support 35 families I have about 45 on
the waiting list for referrals that
aren't getting no services that we could
serve if we had had the staff
so so if we gave you a 15 increase you'd
say you'd serve all the additional 45 on
that's why we asked for 40 percent
that's what we're trying to get to the
rates that Mass health is paying and
they're doing overtime
student loan forgiveness
scholarships they are throwing so much
money into it and that's why we're
losing nurses over the border so
um you know I think the department has a
really difficult challenge when you're
going through those rates and you're
trying to look at things and you look at
around the state the neighboring states
and you look at Medicare and you look at
the market rates you know I looked at Mr
lipman's uh now rate setting on this one
that's in his packet you know you look
at Vermont they're only paying 39 an
hour I don't want to be compared to
Vermont I mean if if they're paying 39
an hour that's their problem but don't
average the rate so that it brings us
down we need to be competitive in the
marketplace that we're in
and when it comes to saving money one
trip to a neonatal Intensive Care Unit
or a flight on Dart to Boston Children's
is going to cost and then a stay of a
week or two weeks is going to cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars thank
you thank you so much for your time
I think we had thank you
another member of the public that wanted
sorry thank you Mr chairman my name is
Gary cohoon I'm a former presidential
care provider because my home run out of
business in May of 2022 uh and with me
is Alex katrubis who I think you know uh
and he is the lobbyist for the New
Hampshire Association of Residential
um
so before you get talking and thank you
for coming
I I just want to make sure that we're
tracking
which line we're going to be hearing
about you and I believe you have a hard
time knowing that no I'm asking if Mr
Ripple or Mr White or Mr lippman is able
to direct us we're going to hear about
CFI mid-level care assisted living is
that what we just did on nine page 934
that's correct line 505.
okay yeah
so so because this is a a March 7th item
if you could just give us the highlights
okay
um
very briefly um you did a kind of a
quick overview at CFI was uh the way
that ResCare fits into the CFI umbrella
is that um
there comes a point in which people
cannot be either safely or practically
maintained in their own homes because
they need 24-hour supervision
but they don't need 24-hour nursing care
and that basically is the the slot that
we're talking about people who need 24
hours of supervision and some assistance
with activities of daily living but
don't need round-the-clock nursing care
um Okay so
there was uh there was a gentleman who
was for a long an honorable gentleman
who was for a long time the chair of the
um house finance committee I'm sure you
know who I'm talking about
um and he was famous for saying on
occasion
if you want to talk to me about
increasing rates come to me when homes
are closing
well we've gotten there homes are
closing you have a little chart here
um this is data that I got from the
housing excuse me Healthcare facilities
Administration
these are the 14 Residential Care Homes
that have closed between uh December of
2018 and December of 2022.
the 14 homes represent a total of 164
beds
the 164 beds is relatively insignificant
when compared to the
6534 beds that are licensed in the state
however eight of these homes for CFI
providers
and they totaled 121 beds
121 beds is much more significant when
you're talking about 500
CFI risk care clients which is what
we're talking about
now the thing about the CFI the 500 CFI
clients in 2011 there were 600.
um
and between 2010 and 2022
the number of people in the New
Hampshire who are over the age of 65
increased by 91 000. so you might expect
that the utilization will be going up
but even if you look at line 505 you see
that the utilization is still going down
because it was 12 million dollars
um two years ago and only 11 million
dollars last year I believe that's
because the department transferred on
expended funds out
and the reason that those funds are
unexpended is because there aren't the
providers to provide the service
um so why does it matter if this
utilization is going down
well there are a number of reasons but
the biggest one is that there's a very
significant unmet need
now Gina when she was speaking to you
was able to categorize the unmet need as
the difference between the authorized
services and the paid services
unfortunately we can't do that for
residential care because for residential
care the services aren't authorized
until a provider is found
so if you look at that metric basically
a hundred percent of the need is met but
in fact people are waiting a long time
to get a residential care bed
I owned and operated Friendship Manor
for 37 years we were forced to close in
May of 2022.
we had 22 beds typically I had three or
four vacancies a year on average I got a
referral a week so I got 50 to 60
referrals a year for three or four beds
one of the homes on your chart here
which closed was rosehaven they were the
home that was closest to Nashua that was
a CFI provider
and they had 28 beds so of course so for
a similar number of openings they got
about 250 referrals a year because on
average they got a referral a day
just last week I was talking with one of
the case management providers
so so I'm I'm sorry uh could could we
stick to the numbers you you've got a
proposal here and your proposal says
that there's a current rate per day of
fifty Seven dollars uh State cost is
28.50 and you think it should go to 80
and the state costs will go to 40. right
okay now you heard miss balcus talking
or are we talking about the same line
item or are you on a would would you be
requiring a plus up in a different line
we are the same line in the governor's
budget as as Ms balcus's request okay so
did you hear her request I did uh is her
request redundant or complimentary with
your switch
uh it's complementary I mean our numbers
are not included in hers or I I guess I
can't answer that question well she
she's uh she's not saying just for her
organization she's just saying across
the board in CFI Services she's
recommending various rates are you in
agreement with her are you are you
adding a different category that we
should be looking at if you're going to
be seeing the budget that way I'm in
agreement with you but I I know that
Gina was speaking to the need for Home
Care not to the need for uh Residential
Care okay so where it says home health
aid that's different than what you're
talking about you're talking about your
own residential kind of setting that's
correct okay and and is it do you think
that's also in line 506 home support
waiver services that doesn't sound like
it would be there I I believe it is I
believe that all the waiver services for
CFI have been grouped in a single line
but I'm not an expert on the budget okay
all right so
um
so so I think you know go ahead
represent and we may take this up on
March 7th would Mr White know if that is
true
we're all in agreement that there's a
problem out there I didn't mean to cut
off the the stories of because we know
that they're there that's why we're here
worrying about the money so it's not the
other way around
yes so on page 934 the governor's
recommended budget accounting unit 2152
[Music]
um the the class lines of 505 506 and
529 have been combined into that single
class line
so the line that Mr Coop would need in
order to support his CFI mid-level care
is that also combined into
506 yes
all right so if you look at it that way
then yes so so I think we have your
testimony unless I'm grossly
oversimplifying something uh unless you
like to know how we arrived at our
figure uh I I don't think so I I think I
think we're going to have at the end of
the day a requirement to see how much
money we have and where we want to
allocate it I I think we're in a classic
economics 101 situation if we have
unlimited demands and limited resources
okay so I
um but so thank you all right well just
let me assure you we didn't pull it out
of the air no I know you did I can tell
I've worked with Alex before I don't I
I'm sure these are extremely well
is there anyone else from the audience
okay so Mr Lipman
um did did you feel like you and Mr
White had gotten through your agenda for
today
which was simply DHHS Division of
[Music]
foreign
I think the the observation is that
we're pretty aligned with what the
governor's budget had with the couple of
exceptions in the proposed hb2 areas in
terms of those things are in fact funded
then I think we're pretty aligned there
um you know we mentioned I think the the
uh state phase down that Gap there the
the issue of
yeah that's the only one I don't think
we talked about yeah the only other
issue um that that we didn't have an
opportunity to address this morning
um the mmis budget is currently included
in the to be proposed hb2
um and and within that is is the general
fund portion which is roughly 10 million
dollars annually and then the ability to
accept the federal funds as well so so
hp2 has the 10 million in general funds
also is or is that 10 million in hp1
somewhere it has so it has an
appropriation it's a total I believe
it's a little over 20 million dollars
off the top of my head of General funds
and then plus the matching federal
dollars and um that that is consistent
with the way that that was budgeted in
this current biennium I hear you I'm
just wondering if any of the general
funds that you're referring to if
they're in the governor's budget in HP
one or if they're all referenced in hb2
all in hb2 okay that's that's my
question all right
um
yes sir just to clarify did you say 10
million or 20 million
roughly 10 million dollars a year 20
million dollars over the biennium so so
I I can pull the number up if you'd like
well I'm looking at the what we got from
LBA which is 20 million allocated out of
our Surplus in 2023 so I guess that
means 10 million a year you're expecting
to spend yeah yeah the the 20.5 million
and the Federal's about uh double that
is
an equivalent amount the on mmis there's
um a little bit enhanced funding
um some of it's 75 25 75 Federal so it
waits out to over 60 percent uh uh in
that that particular line
okay uh thank you so so I'm gonna I'm
gonna consider your portion on Medicaid
complete is that fair
okay so we're going to close out the uh
the Medicaid portion and we're going to
go back was there another question did I
miss a question
okay so I want to go back to uh
reopening on 527.
um 527 is a proposal to raise a Medicaid
reimbursement rate from 102 115 dollars
per day for assisted living facilities
uh and they're going after the small
ones and I think that's what Mr Coop was
talking about earlier do you Mr Lipman
you ran away I was going to ask you
do you have any testimony to offer us on
. there's an amendment to from uh Ripple
on on that uh the original proposal
targeted certain facilities by bid and
that's not an allowable way for us to
raise the rates and um we have an
analysis uh that I sent to Mr Ripple I
don't know if it's made its way to
yeah I haven't handed that out yet okay
as far as the amendment goes there was
an amendment offered by Representatives
Morgan and Petri I emailed that out but
I also have hard copies if anybody needs
one
Kevin
you just came back yeah right it looks
didn't that change right
um
if if you're ready for us to say
anything yeah uh go go ahead are you are
you ready to talk to the amendment that
we've offered do you're going to give us
some information I you're obviously not
here to defend the amendment I'm just
asking you to explain the amendment as
you understand that sure
um just with me if you want to introduce
yourselves
I'm Christy Roy with rate setting at
DHHS
Rob Berry general counsel of the
division of Medicaid
and um Christie's the individual that
has run these numbers but I guess the
punch line is to to treat all facilities
in the same class
equally at the 115 rate is over 10
million dollar impact
um
and
on top of what other things you've heard
today
so I got to keep coming back to simple
things so the original proposal was just
for small facilities and what I think
I'm hearing you say is we're prohibited
from considering them on that basis we
have to generalize and do a broader
class and that broader class if we did
115 is going to cost us 10 million
dollars is that what you just said the
rate is for a service not for a type of
facility it's not a facility specific or
a facility based rate it's a service
based rate so regardless if it's this
Hep 804 licensed or I believe the other
one was an 805 license if it's the same
service they need to receive the same
rate
it's a service based rate
so if it's if they're proposing 115 per
day what what are they getting now do
is 56
56 that level of care which was the one
that the provider was discussing so so
you're not talking to this document are
you yes
a document that you had asked for last
time so it has the rate change over time
yeah the last rate the 56.88 that's the
standard Residential Care rate the other
levels are additional services so it's a
different dementia additional service
required rate which is why they were
higher
so so that's almost a sixty dollar a day
increase
uh representative
can you remind us what the other
service wise because they were drawing a
distinction between the two services and
and providing reasoning as I recall for
why theirs should be increased
independently correct they were saying
their specific rate because they were
if you look at the the handout the
dementia level one and dementia level
two those are the other rates it's the
same code it's the same service but
we're saying for these other if you have
dementia level one you actually require
more services and therefore receive a
higher rate and then there's an
additional dimensional level where it
would be another higher rate so those
are the three rates so those are the
additional two levels of service that
they were talking about it's dementia
level
severity Acuity if you would on the
service do you have a follow-up okay so
by extension then the 115 is that would
is their proposed new base and the other
rates logically should be higher than
that in order to maintain the relative
structure
correct but as we as it was written we
increased that 10.5 was 115 for all
three levels
okay so but that's not logically
consistent so so it would be up to
somebody logical that we'll never find
in the state house to to figure out what
what the relative adjustments ought to
be and whatever adjustment up there is
in the other two lines it's going to go
over the 10 million that you've already
predicted that's correct we would follow
what is in the bill okay and then to the
council have you read the amendment is
this is this legally sufficient is this
is this the right way to write this
other than the dollar amount I'm not
asking you to to validate the 115 I'm
just asking you to validate the
boilerplate around it so what this
amendment would do would just in effect
increase the rate for that Top Line the
lowest level of Acuity
so logically speaking it wouldn't be
sufficient and I don't think it would be
okay let's go with the representative
Stringham and then representative
all right all right I I appreciate what
you're saying about the size of the
facility do you know if it's also
um uh illegal or inappropriate to to
base a difference in payment on the uh
on the payer mix so say if the payer mix
is more than 50 percent Medicaid that a
different rate may apply
so it's this service again it's a
service based rate so if we could
somehow
Define and identify that the Medicaid
clientele were requiring additional
services
there would be an opportunity maybe to
create another rate but again it's a
service based rate so to adjustify a
rate change it would have to be because
of the additional service they're all
the same class of Provider as far as
providing Residential Care whoever is
not speaking to the amendment but
speaking to the concept of targeted rate
increases this might be an example where
the current reimbursement methodology
drives us to a solution that's not
implementable just on the cost of it you
know for example nursing homes are based
on a I'm not saying this is a solution
but nursing homes have a cost-based
methodology based on the cost that they
accumulate that we pay pay Medicaid
defined costs this particular service
based methodology is it problematic to
as we've outlined here but that's that's
where the complexity of all this gets
into once you start
scratching the surface you have to go
deeper right if you see that in the
handout there's I leave one for
Connecticut a rate for Connecticut in
there and in that rate I did put in a
median and a mean because they are a
cost report based rate
um so they have facility specific rates
targeted based on a cost report when you
open that up you're talking about having
everyone fill out a cost report you're
talking about auditing program Integrity
there's a lot of additional nuances to a
facility specific rate
so quick follow-up that when you look at
the other states that they have one rate
it's largely uh because it's cost based
and so therefore there's not a they
don't necessarily distinguish the
service the tractor within their
so I think I heard that the amendment is
written without respect to the dollar
amount is legally sufficient it's it's
good it's good legislative language but
what I think I'm hearing you say also is
that this hundred and fifteen dollars
per day is problematic because it feels
like it's a service based calculation
and not a cost based calculation which
is required by the regs I think what I
was saying is that by stating four
specifically stating for Hep 804a RC
licensees is the problem that's the
challenge because there are also my
understanding is 805 facilities
providing the same service so you
couldn't Target it so that was what I
was suggesting and I think the secondary
one was the Acuity factor is that the
lowest rate would have the highest rate
in the higher Acuity would have a lower
rate so that's that's uh so does the
department have a recommendation to fix
this
that's I guess what I was getting at I
think in terms of a targeted rate
approach would allow us to change the
methodology we could work on something
but that isn't something we can do in a
week or two it's
part of a bigger overhaul of of this
particular area which it is a waiver
based rate it's a CFI waiver rate which
has a CFI waiver methodology in it where
similar to the other waivers what is
going on right now with rebasing them
having them fill out cost surveys all of
the providers are it's similar to that
it's a waiver so so what's the quickest
you could you could propose a rate
and do it right
it's just it's a minimum of three months
six months I guess it's
if it was a loan right it would take I
think let's do alone and then in the
aggregate I think it could take three to
six months depending on the back and
forth with CMS on the methodology and
um to implement and get the facilities
to be able to do a cost report might
take longer as well in terms of their
ability to adapt to that that payment
methodology you know that so I think in
terms of our part we probably could do
and
in isolation in three to six months
okay but given that we've asked you for
a larger piece of homework what what
what what what what do you think you're
going to need for the the whole
and this the scheme of what we have in
front of us into in terms of looking at
um
you know I think we we feel like we
would need no less than six months to do
the sort of the targeted kind of
analytic work and then if that requires
state plan amendments and some other
things that it would take us some time
beyond that say another
it may take nine months to a year to
work all the way through this whole so
so hypothetically if if uh division
three recommended a finance to retain HB
527 and pick it back up in January of
next year might there
be more homework that's been done that
we could figure out the right way to do
this rate setting
I think that would be true I think it
also may be true depending on what other
options you're considering on rates of
whether there's something that could be
done you know in the interim if we're
losing facilities
so I am worried about that looking at
this list of Residential Care Home
closures there's quite a lot of them and
I just wonder
what what the department thinks we may
want to do to just stop the bleeding
I would I would want to consult with the
program area in this in this instance in
terms of what what that needs to be I'm
I apologize it's that's not an area that
I'm an expert
so what do you all think what do you
think you got something going on
I I might have something going on
um because we're a department of four
people in rate setting right now
um we do have outsourced with other
vendors for some of these waiver rates
that they're looking at and it's
a lot of providers
and
um it definitely takes time to do it
well I think
if you remember the nursing facility
increase and the challenges that
happened with that type of increase own
across the board increases challenging
for our for the department and for the
state and I think what Henry maybe have
is like alluding to is that the rates
aren't consistent across the board for
each provider segment
um
obviously another Band-Aid could be put
it would be a Band-Aid so if the
Band-Aid could stop the bleeding and
keep us from closing down prematurely
any more of these facilities do you have
an idea what we might want to do in the
short term
I I want you to feel good that you're
doing your job properly it's going to
take time but what do we do about the
immediate situation
I guess what I would ask if we could on
March 7th you're going to be meeting
with the CFI group of that we need to
get input from the director in that area
to give you a good answer I feel I'd be
overstepping my program knowledge to to
give you a direct answer and I apologize
just that's all right I I uh so so I
think what what we're going to do you
have any last comments Mr counselor or
uh we got representative Holt with a
thank you I'm hearing you may be coming
back for the March 7th potentially
is it possible I understand that there's
a fee per service I understand why
legally that has to be done
but there's also some sort of
incremental cost there's a there's a
base cost to have any facility that is a
function of the number of beds and then
there's an incremental cost for each
patient that is in that facility is
there a way of structuring it based on
instead of per service
per some baseline that groups them into
small medium large or something because
the inherent cost for a kitchen and all
the other support facilities that are
necessary to have patient one is right
is there is there a base slash margin
model that also could work and would be
legal I would definitely say that's not
a Medicaid rate because the Medicaid
rate and what we're looking at today
does not include room and board so when
you're talking about a lot of those
overhead expenses that are room and
board this is for the Residential Care
room and board is not reimbursed through
Medicaid unless it's an Institutional
rate so that would really only be for a
few facilities like hospitals nursing
facilities and like
I think when we were taught
the one we were talking about a
cost-based methodology it was moving in
the direction that you're suggesting
which is being able to take into account
reasonable costs for the volume that
that they're delivering
follow-up it kind of along the same
lines whether right I was using the
analogy of of room and board related
things but if you're sending someone in
to serve one patient the cost for that
one patient is significantly higher than
them going to see three or four at the
so correct right but so if you're
talking about reimbursing a service I
think now you're considering what is a
reasonable
Service employee to bed ratio right and
then would the state want to look at a
limit to that is it okay to have a
one-to-one if really a you know one
service worker to four is adequate and
appropriate and would you want to be
paying for a one to one over one to four
so I think there are definitely more
intricacies to think about in that
and we have done this in the nursing
home
where we recognize for example Capital
costs at a certain percentile so I think
all these things are doable they're just
they take time to execute on
so what I think I've heard is we're not
going to solve this today
we're going to bring it back up on March
7th so Mr Ripple if we could add HB 527
back to the calendar on the 7th of March
please
and
um you you have a last call you got
anything you want to say there uh I'm
all set thank you okay March 7th just to
be clear you're looking for what would
be sort of a stop Gap
answer on March 7th and yes and
confirmation that you think you would be
able to have a good answer
an actionable answer by January of 2024.
okay okay and and do you like your job
if we give you 10 more are you going to
stay or are you looking into
Massachusetts
very good very good all right well thank
you so much and with that uh HP
527.
okay on my calendar which may be wrong I
show we have an hb527 next Monday is
that really on Tuesday
or did I just have something that
doesn't belong there that was today's I
think was the schedule for next week too
yes oh uh well that was a mistake so
I'll I'll just delete it yes okay thanks
all right
okay so we're gonna recess 527 till 7
March at a time TBD
with that I think we're ready to open at
two o'clock we were scheduled to listen
to the division of children youth and
Families
foreign
I didn't know what I was doing last year
and it was so much easier
a little bit of milk it is so dangerous
we're just having a sidebar we'll be
okay
it's a little after two o'clock we're
gonna open a work session division three
good afternoon uh Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer Health and Human
Services
um before you there are a couple of
documents and I just want to take a
moment just to orient everybody to them
so we have the PowerPoint presentation
that and uh director ribsum is going to
be going through that to orient you to
the appropriate page of the governor's
recommended budget it's page 875 is
where we start
and we also provided you with a copy of
the budget briefing book for for dcyf
and and Prime that will primarily be
there for reference unless there's
specific questions
and then we also provided to you a
document this is the dcyf position
movement there were a number of
positions that were being moved around
through the accounts and I was kind of
envisioning how that conversation would
go and I probably wouldn't be able to
explain it adequately so
um what we did is uh the team put this
together Rebecca Lord and our finance
director behind me I want to give her
credit for this she put this together to
try to answer those questions in advance
so that when we do go through and we see
increases or reductions by each
accounting unit and FTE we're able to
track that so with no further Ado I will
hand it over to Joe
great good afternoon everybody Joe rips
I'm director dcif good to see you all
again
um
so I will start you know walking us
through the presentation here I'm sure
folks will have questions I'm at the
discretion of the chair totally
comfortable taking questions as we go
rather than waiting till the end
um because I think that probably makes
more sense for folks
and you'll notice as you continue to go
through these that the department tried
to
um create kind of a standardized format
for these presentations so you'll see I
think some similarities in the way this
is presented to the other divisions and
probably some differences between how
it's presented this year and how it was
presented last year I'm sorry last
biennium
so turn to page two this just is the the
mission of the division and I'll move
kind of quickly through this stuff
unless folks want me to go deeper we
partner with families and communities
provide resources and supports that lead
to the safety and healthy development of
children youth and the communities in
which they thrive in which they live
and then the next page kind of just
talks about what the key page three
talks about what kind of the key areas
of focus dcyf has so dcyf really has
three key responsibilities Child
Protective Services Juvenile Justice
Services and then the operation of sysc
which this committee has spent a lot of
time talking about already
um almost everything else we do is just
in service to better supporting those
things you'll see we have multiple
bureaus as I get through that but what
those bureaus primarily do is provide
the back office support to make sure
that those things that we do in the
community through these my three kind of
main operations
um are functioning well so child
protective services this is
investigating and assessing allegations
of child abuse and neglect providing for
the safety permanency and well-being of
child victims or children at risk of
maltreatment
so we get um and I'll go through this
with the data but essentially the way
Child Protection Services works we get
calls to our child protection hotline
make allegations of things that may or
may not have happened at the hotline
folks do an assessment either screen in
or screen out or make a referral for
some alternative service and I'll go
deeper into some of this later if things
get screened out they get assigned for
an assessment or an investigation and
during that process staff are doing two
different things one they're assessing
whether or not abuse or neglect has
occurred is defined by law and
separately they're assessing kind of the
the needs and risk profile of the family
using an Actuarial tool and based on
what comes back from that information
we'll then determine if we'll move
forward with potentially a court case in
rare instances a child being removed
from their home that is actually quite
rare right we do over ten thousand
assessments a year removals are counted
in the hundreds right so people often
think that this is a system that removes
children pretty regularly it's actually
a pretty rare instance that children get
removed
um what happens more often than not is a
family is offered some type of services
either within the system or made a
referral to something outside of the
child protection system
the next section here is Juvenile
Justice Services support Children and
Youth to remediate challenges with
delinquency to promote child family and
Community safety support Children and
Youth identified as children in need of
services
so the typical pathway for Juvenile
Justice case is a young person has
contact with law enforcement
law enforcement would then potentially
file some type of petition
and we would then you know if a petition
is filed we get engaged at that point if
the youth is put on probation or youth
is sent to sysc were then engaged
through those processes we did have a
major change last year in this that I'll
want to talk about in more depth as we
get into this around a new process that
happens in juvenile justice that we call
an assessment process whereas now when
law enforcement has contact with a young
person they then refer them to us to do
a child adolescent needs and strengths
assessment and we then use that
assessment to make a recommendation back
as to whether this child really needs
Court intervention or whether we can
meet the needs of this child in the
community and I have some data on how
that new system is working it's been
operational for only about a year at
this point
the last piece of your children in need
of services
that happens in a couple different ways
there's what's called voluntary chins
children in need of services chins is
how people refer to this that occurs
when a child is struggling sometimes in
school or some other place and the
family or the school is calling up for
us to provide some additional support
for that young person those voluntary
chins can only be in-home services they
cannot be residential services and then
there's something called
which we refer to kind of a D2 chins or
an involuntary chins that is where and
we see less and less of this thanks to
the the new system of care that's been
running for a few years now but that's
where a family would go into court and
have to make an allegation to a judge
that their child is so out of control
that they need the judge to put that
child into residential treatment
fortunately those happen less and less
today because the system of care has now
offered an alternative pathway for those
families to get help which is a great
thing right imagine if you're the parent
and you're trying to have this you know
this care provided to your child and the
only way you could do it is going to
court and telling the court that your
child is out of control and they're
dangerous that doesn't really lead to a
very
therapeutic productive relationship
between the parent and child inclination
the way that it needs to in order for
that child to be able to safely come
back to the community now with the
system of care those kids can access
that service through the new Care
Management entities through the fast
forward program and no longer have to go
through that process so that's really a
great thing but this D2 chins process is
still on the books and infrequently it
is still used where we're not able to
get a young person to voluntarily engage
through the children's Behavioral Health
Care system
and then lastly sysc which we've spent a
lot of time talking about over the last
couple weeks but the purpose there
provide a safe and secure environment
for detained and committed youth that
receive Crisis Intervention mental
health and treatment services in a
secured setting ensure the safety and
well-being of committed and detained
Youth and the overall safety of the
community what page does sysc start on
well we mention it here on page three
but on in the actual powering point in
and what's unusual there is I believe
the actual sysc operating expenses are
which stems from last biennium's
decision
um during the budget process that makes
the budget to hb2
yeah
[Music]
it makes sense yeah so so that's why
when you're looking at uh the the 24 and
keep going okay I'm going to move on to
page four is just kind of the high level
organizational chart of the division
um
as I said kind of the the bulk of our
work is child protection and Juvenile
Justice in the field and that falls
under the second box here that says
Field Services
so all of our juvenile probation
officers all of our cpsws all of our
district offices they all fall into this
this operation as field services and
then sysc which we're all familiar with
everything else here is really in
support to making sure that those two
things can work well so so if I wanted
to look at the budget where it says
Personnel for Field Services what page
so
what's going to happen is is we're going
to go to key challenges next and then
and then beginning on slide seven
um we have all of the accounting units
listed for each Bureau area and then
we'll be able to go through those in in
okay
so the other primary
um operations within dcyf is our office
of Chief our chief of legal Regulatory
and legislative affairs who
interacts here with the legislature
provides general counsel to the
department oversees our policy
operations and a handful of other
regulatory development and things like
that our chief of operations who
oversees our Bureau of professional
strategic development our Bureau of
evaluation analytics and Reporting on
our business Information Systems all of
these are going to be gone into a little
bit deeper this is just the high level
to orient you
our Bureau of community family and
program support reports directly to
Maine not through the chief of
operations and that's the bureau that's
really responsible for all of our
services in the community all of our
contracts for services all of our
procurements for services they also
oversee specialty areas like foster care
adoption and things like that our youth
our youth work our youth aging out of
foster care work the Hope program which
is voluntary foster care to age 21 which
I can go into deeper later and then
finally sysc which folks are familiar
with
so page five no
page five lays out uh kind of what we
see as key accomplishments of the last
biennium
and I broke these up into a couple
different ways I'm one right this idea
providing earlier supports that support
children and strengthen families
um
one of the key things that we're working
on right now is a new procurement which
we're in final negotiations on for
something called a community navigator
at Child Protection intake that's been
procured and is currently in negotiation
what the community Navigator is is when
somebody calls the hotline for child
abuse and neglect and they make a
they're making an allegation
historically we only had two options to
offer that person either you're
screening in and you're doing an
investigation or you're screening out
now we have a third option that's going
to be available which is that we can
then try to help connect that family to
services so it's not uncommon at all
that we'll get a call to the hotline
where it doesn't it doesn't allege abuse
or neglect but there's clearly a need
for a family simple idea
Teacher Calls because a child's coming
to school without adequate breakfast in
the morning
that's not really abuse or neglect
typically what that typically is an
issue around poverty or an issue around
access to food security so in that
instance the community Navigator could
then work with that teacher to help that
teacher figure out how do you get that
family to the help that they need
without having to have child protection
go out and get involved in that family
unnecessarily
next big thing here community-based
voluntary services this was a big deal a
few years ago
just four or five years ago before I got
here and up until a year afterwards as a
matter of law we were not allowed to
provide a voluntary service to a family
a family would come to our attention
we'd conduct an assessment we would say
it's not abuse or neglect but there's a
whole lot of needs here
there's high risk here we use an
Actuarial tool that identifies whether
there's risk in families but we wouldn't
actually have the authority to provide
any type of service to help support that
family that was changed a few years ago
in law and now we have a couple
different Pathways what we call
Community for what we call voluntary
services that is the ability to work
with the family on a voluntary basis
One Is Us opening up our own voluntary
case there's only a handful of those a
year because of caseload issues and
other things it's tough to open up too
many of those the other is this new
model called community-based voluntary
Services where we contract with two
major providers Waypoint for most of the
state and the Family Resource Center
Center at Gorham for the North country
so when we do an assessment we will
identify that this is a family that has
some needs that we're not going to be
able to meet because right we're not
opening up our own case we're not going
to court with this and that provider
will then voluntarily work with that
family to try to meet those needs
identify what's going on strengthen that
family and hopefully keep that family
from coming back to us repeatedly as
historically happened
next big accomplishment here is the JJ
assessment process which was Senate Bill
94 from 2021 this is the one I talked
about a little while ago and now
implemented straight Statewide this is
when kids have contact with law
enforcement they get referred to us and
we then conduct a cans child adolescent
needs and strengths tool and use that to
identify whether this is a young person
who has needs that can be met in the
community or these needs that really
need to go to court and as I'll go
through the data a little bit later
you'll see overwhelmingly we've been
able to identify young people and keep
them out of the court process and send
them on to community-based services to
meet their needs instead of going to
court last year which was the first year
that we did this it started in January
of last year in one third of the state
July of last year went to the next third
of the state October of last year went
Statewide and last year we were able to
conduct a little over a thousand
assessments I do anticipate next year is
going to be higher because it won't be a
rolling implementation anymore it's just
going to be the normal way that we do
business and there's data in here that
talks about that a little bit more
deeply
um next big thing here I talk about is
the kinship Navigator programs which we
stood up a few years ago in partnership
with public health and with division of
Economic and housing stability
those are programs for
grandparents Aunts Uncles anybody who is
caring for a young person
because of needs in that family outside
of the formal child protection system so
we often have kids come into foster care
but it's also very very common for young
people to end up living with a
grandmother without us being involved or
living with an aunt or uncle or some
other person who cares for them without
of these four four bullets here under
providing earlier supports
are all of these completely voluntary on
the part of the family is there any
coercion or compulsion in any of these
no it's all completely voluntary
families don't have to participate in
any of these things so really it's a
it's a way of doing business which you
know we think is going to be much more
successful with families getting them
the help that they need based on their
desire to engage as opposed to thank you
right when you have core involvement
so this last program can ship a
navigation though has been really huge
in getting kids and families
um who are you know folks who are living
with these grandparents and others the
support that they need in order to try
to help them you know navigate the
benefit system if they qualify for TANF
benefits Med navigate the court
processes if they need to get
guardianship for a young person help
them through the school process help
them deal with the changing
relationships that they're experiencing
right you can imagine if you're a
grandparent and all of a sudden you're
caring for your grandchild as your own
child that might put a strain on your
relationship with your with your child
of course right that's a different way
of having to work with those folks and
these Community these kinship navigation
programs really help those folks manage
these change Dynamics so they can
provide care for their for their
grandchildren or other relatives or you
know whatever that structure is within
the family
next big bucket here talking about
higher quality supports when formal
system involvement is required so
everything I just spoke about there was
really ways that we're trying to get to
families before formal systems
involvement or if they touch the formal
system to try to divert them away from
the formal system into community-based
supports
the next big area that we've been
working on is how do we improve for
those handful of families that do need
to formally come into the system
um one big piece of this is the federal
Family First preventative Services act
prevention plan which we had approved by
the feds in October of 2022 family first
made really two big changes in federal
law in the way that we have to operate
our systems one for residential care put
in a bunch of new requirements that
we've operationalized through the Bureau
of children's Behavioral Health they'll
go into more depth about that but we
talked a little bit at prior hearings
about the new contract process we went
through there the new requirements on
those programs that is all stuff that's
aligned with family first the new cat
assessments that we talked about all of
that stuff is part of the family first
requirements for residential care the
other piece is that it allowed the
states to start to draw down federal
funds to help support programs for
families who are at risk of having their
kids enter foster care and that's a
somewhat more narrow definition than
some people think some people thought
that meant basically any family could
receive these Services that's not the
way the feds have defined it it really
is families who come to our attention
through say a child protection
assessment we make a determination that
they're at risk of entering foster care
as a result of that but if we put in XYZ
service we can keep those kids safe at
home and then the feds will allow us to
we'll reimburse us for part of the cost
of evidence-based models that meet their
criteria and they created an
evidence-based Clearinghouse and
identified which program models and
stuff that we could use we've
implemented two and are in the process
of implementing our third evidence-based
program in the past couple years based
off of this the first was multi-systemic
therapy which is a program really
targeted for those adolescents who
typically folks would think of as having
you know quote unquote Behavior
challenges that works closely and deeply
with the family and the young person
around kind of stabilizing the home
environment helping the the family unit
understand how to manage The Young
Person's behaviors and helping the
family then shape and and remold The
Young Person's behaviors towards things
that we that we want Young Folks to do
the next is one called Youth Villages
intercept which has been procured in and
implemented that one is a program that's
more for use on the child protection
side of the house focuses more on the
parental supports necessary for families
who are struggling with you know keeping
their kids safe and doing the things
that they need to do for their children
Works closely with those families around
those challenges and then the final one
is the Healthy Families America program
we procured that last summer in
partnership with public health and that
is a home visitation program
the historical model only allowed them
to work with folks if they engaged in
the program before the child was two
weeks old you can imagine for our
population trying to get to a child and
getting a family engaged before a child
is two weeks old is pretty difficult
um so there is a there's a newer model
called the Child Welfare protocols that
have been approved under the family
first Clearinghouse which allows you to
to open up a program for a child up to
24 months old so we have actually a lot
of families who would qualify for that
program and that would then put a home
visitor in to work with families who are
at you know high risk oftentimes the
families who benefit for this benefit
from this are you know kids who are
maybe born with substance exposure or
kids who are born with other types of
challenges that are identified even at
the moment of birth in the hospital and
then we start working with the family
and trying to put services in place to
keep that family together
other key um accomplishments that I
would point to around this higher
quality supports is the work with
children's Behavioral Health on building
out that system of care things like fast
forward and track that we spoke about
extensively over the past couple weeks
things like the residential redesign and
the cat assessments that we spoke about
over the past couple weeks we've really
built this system to be integrated with
dcyf Juvenile Justice and child
protection and not just being a
standalone system but rather whenever
kids have Behavioral Health Care needs
we want them going there rather than
coming to us to have those needs met
because if they're with children's
Behavioral Health they can continue to
have their needs met after we're done
right child protection
right that's about kids it's about
keeping family about families it's about
what's happening in that household and
parents Juvenile Justice it's about
delinquency children's Behavioral Health
happens throughout all of these but if
we end up becoming the system that has
to provide children's Behavioral Health
Care then families have to stay engaged
with us longer than necessary right we
want to be able to close out our case as
soon as we deal with the child
protection issue but if that kid has a
behavioral health need the system of
care is still there closeout or
delinquency case on the Juvenile Justice
side as soon as that issue is resolved
but if that kid has ongoing Behavioral
Health Care needs the system of care is
still there historically that's not how
the systems have worked historically
we've had to keep cases open
indefinitely just to provide these
Services for Families and now we don't
um next key accomplishment this is a
statute that passed last year and we're
in the process of a major procurement on
this which is a kinship care expansion
so we talked a little bit while ago
about the kinship Navigator programs
another key place that you use kin and
that is anybody who really has a
pre-existing loving caring relationship
with a child and who would be an
appropriate caregiver is in the actual
foster care system so if a child does
have to come into our custody the best
thing that we want to do is identify
someone who already knows and loves that
child and keep that child with that
person right whether that's grand mom
whether that's Aunt or Uncle whether
that's the neighbor who's been involved
in this kid's life forever whatever it
is whether it's a member of the faith
community we want to think of these
things broadly obviously relatives are
the most common but they're not the only
type and law was changed last year to
allow us to think more broadly about
these kinship providers to include these
other types of folks and we're in the
process of we've already procured we're
in the negotiation process with a vendor
to provide additional support for these
folks and to be able to actually license
these folks as a special type of kinship
foster parent
which will provide them additional
support training in a way that we
haven't been able to do before and the
hopes of this is that by providing this
additional supports and training we'll
be able to increase the number of kids
in kinship care which is good for the
kid it's less trauma
tend to have shorter lengths of stay in
foster care when you're working with Ken
even if that child reunifies they tend
to reunify back home with their parents
and they've built a support system with
that caregiver whether it's Grandma or
whomever else
but it's also really good because we
have real challenges right now around
finding placements for young people
entering foster care right the number of
foster homes is kind of diminished or
decreased During the covid period we've
also had real challenges around
Residential Care as we've spoken about
here
so by increasing the number of kids with
kin we can decrease the pressures on
those other parts of the system that are
really struggling to keep up as I recall
the foster parent program was under a
lot of stress before the pandemic that
we were seeing declining interest in the
Foster program on the part of host
families prior to the pandemic I don't I
don't think the data supports it I think
what we really saw was when the pandemic
hit the recruitment levels come down and
I can I can go back and pull the old
data books on that but
the the number of licensed foster
parents really was steadily increasing
from about 20 17 18 19 and then really
took a hit during the pandemic
so but currently we think we have an
inadequate supply of foster parents I
yes I think right now 20 more 50 more
100 what do you oh I would say probably
I would like to see 50 more you know
what you want to see is do you want to
have enough foster homes available so
there are multiple options in every
Community for every kid
that being said there's multiple ways to
get to that problem right one way is
about recruiting foster parents but
another key way is about increasing
kinship care which is probably the
preferred option for all kids right if
you have an available kin that's willing
to care for that child that's the best
place for the child debate currently we
only get about a third of our kids in
kinship Care New Jersey where I came
from we got about half of our kids there
some places like Allegheny County who've
implemented this model that we're
working on implementing right now get 70
plus percent of their kids you can ship
care out of state yes and actually we
just entered into what is called a
provisional placement agreement with
Massachusetts for that exact purpose
okay because the can the kinship even if
they're out of state there's some still
some supervisory role that the state
provides under the interstate compact
for the placement of children the other
state has a responsibility to help do
the licensure process for that kinship
provider and help provide supervision
for that kinship provider representative
just that we're talking the same
language can you better Define who was
included in kinship right obviously
immediate family but how much broader
does it go yeah so statute was changed
last year on top of my head I'm not
remembering the the citation of that but
I can get that for you and um the
language is quite broad it basically is
anybody who has a pre-existing caring
relationship with a child or their
parents right so the most common is a
grandparent but it could be a member of
the faith community it could be a family
friend
it could be anybody who has that
pre-existing relationship with the
parent and family
follow-up
do you remember what that statute change
was I'll have I'll have to look it up I
can give you the citation though as part
of a big piece of legislation that
passed last year with a whole lot of
Human Services stuff in it
should be two
it wasn't hb2 it was I don't remember
the number so the key thing I'm hearing
you say is the eligibility under the
Kinship Program really has very little
to do with being a blood relationship of
any kind it's just right it's a
friendship relationship is even adequate
right any type of kind of again
pre-existing caring relationship with
the child and or the family so you know
we hear stories and we've seen kids have
very successful opportunities with the
person who was the school bus driver who
knew this kid for six years you know you
see lots of really really interesting
things come up
show the hair on the back of my neck
goes up here in that but so we're doing
this in a safe way where kids are
I don't know why that just made me yeah
so part of this new process is actually
to have those folks go through a
licensure process which wasn't right
before this law change we didn't have a
licensure process so it really was
limited to only relatives now with this
new change these folks will go through
the full licensure process which
includes a home study we always did a
basic criminal background check but
includes all those types of things as
well
okay
sure you you you haven't you have a new
director it looks like from this bullet
you have a new director and you're
already implementing the
trauma-informed therapeutic we're trying
our best as I talked about here right
there's limitations of how far we can go
but we did hire a new director in August
our prior director
um retired last December or January I'm
not remembering right now the new
director does have a clinical background
themselves which is great this is the
first time we had a clinician actually
in charge of the facility and we've been
able to finally as of two weeks ago fill
the clinical positions through our
contract with Dartmouth we have a
contract with Dartmouth to have
clinicians and a psychologist on site it
took them over a year almost a year to
fill the first clinical positions and
the over position and over a year to
fill the second one but we now do have a
full team of clinicians director
position are you requiring an advanced
degree a PhD what do you what what kind
of job qualification is that yeah so we
were so the requirement I think was a
master's level but what I was really
looking for was somebody who was a
licensed clinician themselves who also
had experience leading
um you know a clinical residential
program which this individual does
those are hard to find even they are and
that's one of the reasons I think it
took eight ten months to fill it
representable
thank you chairman I believe I met this
new director Mr Thursday what was her
name Mr Rocha wrote Gerald Roche is the
director and Samantha Morin's the
psychologist I think you met both of
okay
um the other big thing on here we jumped
ahead a little bit to sysc was the
Juvenile Justice rules of probation so
we were able to work with the courts to
change the rules of probation for
juveniles um so even when a young person
does go to court historically there was
20 set in stone rules that never changed
no matter what the underlying issue was
and that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense for young people we were able to
change that with the Supreme Court
approving the rule change to have them
be customized based on what the child
actually did and what their needs
actually are and the cans assessment
helps inform what the individualized
rules of probation are for young people
there are some that are standard right
we don't want kids having weapons we
don't want kids doing drugs but there's
a lot of things that are customized
based on what the underlying offense is
and then the last big bucket here of
accomplishments I would talk about
additional support for transition aged
youth
so a few years ago we were able to
expand the Foster Care Program in the
state to include voluntary foster care
for young people up to age 21. so before
that at age 18 unless you were still in
high school and then you could stay
until you graduated high school you were
let go out of the system at that point
and you were on your own and for a lot
of our young people
they were not successful a lot of young
people ended up homeless ended up in
lots of bad places because they weren't
ready at 18 to be able to do this with
the expansion of voluntary foster care
to age 21 which are young people named
The Hope program
stands for housing and opportunities for
personal Excellence that was they came
up with that not me and I think it's
great
but with that we now have you know quite
a few young people who at 18 decide to
stay with us and will then continue to
support them up through age 21 you know
if they choose to it's not it's not
required and you'll as we talk a little
bit further through this you'll see some
other things that are changing in the
system that we're asking for to try to
better support those young people as we
move on
thank you representative hole for a
question sure on this voluntary program
is the state picking up the call so just
help me understand the foster care
system right I believe the state picks
up some of the costs for children up
through 18 does that then go on in this
program 321 or is it just allowing them
to stay there because they've chosen to
stay there no so it does there is
um the way Foster Care is funded is
primarily through something called title
IV of the Social Security Act
and title 4E is just like Medicaid kind
of a a matched entitlement program right
so for you for families who qualify
um half of the cost is picked up by the
federal government the other half of the
cost is picked up by the state so the um
the expansion of this program we then
modified our plan with the feds to be
able to include this population in that
program so the feds do pay for part of
it but just like other foster care they
um the housing opportunities for young
people there could be foster homes could
be group homes could be new Independent
Living programs that we've set up but
for some other young people who are
ready for it we'll be able to support
them in moving into Apartments
um if they're going to college support
them through their on-campus housing
and other shared uh shared living
arrangements so sometimes young people
choose to to live together you know
they'll choose to rent an apartment
together and we can help support that
process through this
another big change over the past couple
years was the implementation of
something called Youth Villages life set
YB life set which is an evidence-based
program for transitioned youth
transition aged youth to kind of help
them do the type of planning and get
ready for independent successful
adulthood the way that you know all of
us would want to do with our own kids
and then last big partnership has been
with the housing authorities over the
past couple years
both the local and the state to be able
to apply to HUD for different types of
housing vouchers to support young people
who have aged out of foster care or
families who are at risk of entering
foster care as a result of housing
instability
and if there's no other questions on
that I'll move on to the next page which
is key challenges
age six correct yes that's right thank
you
okay key challenges
um I think the biggest one that I put
forward is Workforce which I think
you've heard in a lot of other forums as
well hiring and retaining child
protection and sysc staff remains a
significant challenge we're actually
doing better with child protection staff
than we had been in years past I think
the current vacancy rate is about 15
percent which while still tough is
better than I think the Department's
average vacancy rate and better than the
state's average vacancy rate at this
point which is you know saying something
given um you know kind of how far behind
we were just a few years ago but we
still need to get those positions filled
um recent data shows that actually we
have an increasing demand and I'll walk
through this data with folks but an
increasing demand at intake that's at
the hotline for call volume and
increasing demand for no child
protection assessments and then
increasing demand for family service
cases those are the cases that actually
do have to get brought in and go to
court over the past year adding
additional pressure to the system
some things that have helped we have had
pain enhancements through the last
biennium for child protection and sysc
staff and that has helped I think reduce
the vacancy rate and improve stability
of the workforce there and probably why
we're better than we were a couple years
ago and maybe better than the Statewide
average but we're still not quite where
we need to be and I'm hopeful that
between those increases and through
salary increases that have been part of
the collecting bargaining program will
will see increased retention increase
hiring capacity for these key positions
um we did ask for in our prioritized
needs a couple different things one was
to create something called an impact
team to help mitigate the cascading
impact of turnover over the past few
years and this is a model that we used
in New Jersey to try to help stabilize
uh when you start seeing turnover in the
field so you can imagine if you're
working in a district office and a
couple people leave all their work gets
redistributed to other staff that then
actually in many instances has actually
contributed to increased turnover where
those other staff feel overwhelmed and
then they look to leave too what the
impact team would be and what we set up
in New Jersey to try to prevent that
from happening it's a central Statewide
group that could be deployed to those
offices when those things happen so that
you could prevent that kind of overflow
and that overwhelming of staff that then
leads to cascading and growing turnover
within those offices so we did put in a
prioritized needs request for that we
also put in a prioritize needs request
for 12 additional case Aid positions so
this is a new position we created first
time a few years ago it's kind of like a
paraprofessional type perfect position
for child protection workers oftentimes
we'll get Young Folks younger folks in
there who maybe finished an associate's
degree or something like that and want
to go on to get a bachelor's degree and
to become Child Protection workers and
they'll step into these roles where they
can you know help transport kids
supervise visits help with paperwork
whatever it is it's more of a
paraprofessional role and then a lot of
times we're actually seeing these people
then be able to move up into the child
protection positions which is really
great to have that kind of stepping
stone for folks to have some career
advancement
um in a way that we haven't had before
the hope is that if we're able to add
some more of these folks it would
relieve some pressure from our Frontline
staff which have been harder positions
representative talerski for a question
thank you regarding the staff challenges
at um the youth center I recall you
saying that you remove workers got moved
around different places to cover some
severe needs where there were vacancies
where all those workers compensated at a
level that they should have been or did
you have to use enhancements to get them
to cover those spots or are there
different
problems that come up with that yes so
at sysc as we as we've shared here
before right we're running with a major
major vacancies right we need about 40
to 45 front line youth counselors we
call them we have I think it's 17 on the
books today although we have a couple in
the pipeline that are that look like
we're going to have a couple of the
positions filled um which is great
um not anywhere near what we need but
it's good to finally see some people
applying for and starting to jump into
these jobs
um
so we've been filling those gaps with
lots and lots of overtime over time
offered to folks who work elsewhere in
DHHS and also over time to folks who
have been mandated to work down there so
our juvenile probation staff have
sometimes been mandated to work done
there we're currently operating under a
mandate meaning that if we're short we
will require staff based in seniority
order we go through the list to go down
there and cover shifts and pick up
fortunately the last few weeks we've had
enough volunteers that nobody had to be
mandated but it's still kind of a threat
at any given time that if the census
goes up and we need additional staff to
keep it safe or if we don't have enough
volunteers at any given time that we
could be mandating staff to go in so
those staff do get time and a half for
their time there but I think there's a
lot of frustration amongst a lot of
those staff because I spoke before about
the enhancements that are occurring
right so our child protection staff are
receiving enhancements and our youth
counselors are receiving enhancements
but the juvenile probation staff do not
so I think there's you know it's
definitely had a morale hit on those
folks who really feel like they've been
stepping up and and doing more but they
don't qualify for those enhancements
follow up thanks can you explain why
they don't qualify for that
sure so the enhancement process as I
best understand it and I'm not the
expert but the enhancement process is
the statutory process where when you
look at certain types of positions and
there's critical levels of vacancy as
you can go before dop and then GNC to
get approval for a salary enhancement to
bring those levels to a bring that pay
to a level where you can hire additional
staff the juvenile probation officers
those positions are actually been pretty
well staffed which is great but they
don't quite fit into that categorization
of of being so short staffed that they
would require an enhancement to get
those positions filled while that makes
sense to me from the way that that
process works it does definitely have
you know morale impacts across across
staff feeling like they're not being
treated you know equally across the
division
um where was I
okay I was moving on to the next section
which was additional support for
alternative caregivers
um what we've seen in the past few years
so caregivers when I talk about
caregivers I'm talking about lots of
different places these are folks who are
caring for children that are not their
own right it could be foster parents
could be adoptive parents could be in a
residential program
um lots of different places but we have
seen caregivers being under increased
Financial stress in recent years due to
Major economic shifts and local Regional
and National shortages of options for
children in need of out of home care so
basically what I'm talking about here is
what we're just talking about a minute
ago right foster care not quite having
enough foster parents that we need
foster parents not having
reimbursement rates that align with the
current costs of raising children
anymore and residential programs not
having the workforce necessary to have
their beds open to meet all the needs
and that puts a lot of pressure on our
staff when they're trying to find a safe
place for a child to be in a crisis
situation we did have we do have a
prioritized need in the budget request
to increase foster care rates to align
with the USDA media cost of raising a
child in New Hampshire
and I believe the governor did identify
that one in the governor's proposed
budget as one to fund so I'd hope to
continue to have support for that
there's also a prioritized need in the
behavioral health budget which I'm sure
they'll go into more deeply around doing
a similar thing for residential programs
as I mentioned before right Behavioral
Health we've kind of intentionally put
Behavioral Health in charge of things
like residential care because right if a
kid's going there it's because yes they
need a place to live but also because
they need treatment so we intentionally
have moved oversight of those away from
dcyf into children's Behavioral Health
but a lot of the kids they serve are our
kids right they're the dcyf kids and
those programs are really struggling to
open up all their beds because of
Workforce issues
I mentioned before this um in the key uh
in the key accomplishments the work
around Kinship Caregivers so we are
going to be creating a new kinship
caregiver license type which will allow
allows us to waive some of the things
that are required for regular foster
parents things like room sizes and stuff
like that that isn't really key to a
child's safety or well-being and when
you're kind of balancing you know the
size of a bedroom for staying with
Grandmom it should be a pretty easy
decision for most people that even if
the bedroom's smaller staying with
Grandma's probably the best thing for
the kid well historically you couldn't
actually make that decision and license
that grandmother if her room size wasn't
right the feds allow you to waive things
like that for kin so we're going through
creating a new licensure scheme for
those Kinship Caregivers So eventually
when that's ready that'll be coming back
to the legislature through jail car to
take a look at that
um
it is going to be slightly delayed from
where we originally thought because the
feds are actually in the process of
redoing their regs related to this and
we don't want to put out a new
regulatory scheme and then find out six
months later that we did something that
has to be Rewritten all over again so
we're going to wait to see what the feds
do before we bring that back here the
original goal was to get that to the
legislature this spring but it'll
probably be a little more like this fall
while we wait for the feds to finish
their piece of it
and then there is a piece of legislation
out there that I think is also helpful
for caregivers SB 172. and what this
would do is it would allow the TANF
benefit that currently can go to like
grandparents and relative caregivers to
also go to those fictive kin caregivers
right those people that we were just
talking about like the the neighbor
who's been involved in the child's life
we heard lots of testimony from these
folks who have stepped up to care for
kids but they don't qualify for that
benefit the feds would allow us to use
TANF dollars for that purpose but we do
need to change our statute to align with
that so that's a piece of legislation
that I anticipate will clear the Senate
and be coming over here at some point
and then lastly in the key challenges
area it's additional support for
children youth and families so
recent unanticipated system changes have
shifted Demand on necessary programs and
services to support children youth and
families outside of the formal child
protection of Juvenile Justice System
you do have a prioritized need in our
request for Statewide Juvenile Diversion
programming one of the things that we're
seeing as we're going through the new
assessment process is that we're
identifying kids who need a diversion
program and what diversion programs do
is a restorative justice program with
young people
um unfortunately we don't have those
programs all over the state because
they're locally funded and some
communities choose to do them and other
communities don't choose to do them so
we're doing now a Statewide process to
assess needs but not every kid depending
on where they live has access to that
kind of service which is a problem so
the hope is for support to be able to
fund a Statewide Juvenile Diversion
program to be able to provide that
service equitably across the state to
all of our kids
so I'm going to piggyback off of your
use of the word equity and just ask if
you're working with the the new director
Reuben Hampton to make sure that that
any gaps that we have or he can help
identify and re settle down on fixing
those yep absolutely and honestly I
haven't I've met Reuben but he and I
haven't had our kind of first one-to-one
intro meeting I think it's on the books
for later this week so I'm looking
forward to that but yes that'll be a key
um there was our next one here
um there's a prioritized need that will
be coming forward from the division of
economic stability to better support
Family Resource Centers so I talked a
little bit a little while ago about the
new community Navigator program that
we're standing up we anticipate that
with that we're going to have more and
more referrals to Our Family Resource
Centers but historically again the state
hasn't actually funded their operations
they're locally funded some are better
resourced than others some places of the
state we don't have access at all and
you'll hear more about that when when
economic stability comes forward to to
give their presentation and then lastly
there is a bill moving through the
Senate right now Senate Bill 154 it's in
partnership with UNH in the community
college system and it authorizes an
expansion of the tuition waiver program
so
yes
are we going to ask anything in return
because there are a lot of families that
would like some tuition assistance if
we're going to provide tuition
assistance are we going to receive
something back like you know they're
going to go into a shortage area like
health care or so this is this is a
program that already exists on the books
for young people who are aging out of
foster care who were adopted out of
foster care and it has I think about 30
or 35 slots right now and what we've
seen with the expansion of the Hope
program is the ability of more and more
young people to actually enter a program
is there any obligated service any
payback on their part the obligated
service of the payback I think is
actually having our young people leave
foster care and be productive members of
society oh no so there's not a
requirement that they do XYZ thing after
they complete the program now okay I
mean in the military people go to
Afghanistan in order to get some help
with college I don't think leaving
foster care quite Rises to that level
but I you know I think we have a lot of
young folks who have for a long time
struggled to be able to get on their
feet and don't have all the advantages
that a lot of other folks have when
entering um you know trying to figure
out how to enter the workforce and such
and this is a program that the
university system the community college
system is eager to support us with
doesn't actually require the state to
put additional resources into it thank
you yep
and I will move on to page seven if
folks
I can try to talk more quickly those two
slides were the dense system Mr Ripple
in in two years if we're back at this
again
this this stuff that we heard up until
now is all great material but this would
be really good to have before the budget
shows up because because I these were
not Financial numbers you know these are
programs accomplishments all great
information but we have such a scarce
amount of time to deal with the budget
that uh if we could you know shift it in
the future that would be great
sure
all right so this is kind of just
showing you where everything exists
within the Bureau of field services
budget again field service is
responsible for all Juvenile Justice and
Child Protection field operations
exercise Statewide through our district
office structure
um that includes our assessments our
ongoing cases Court work service
matching placements etc for both
Juvenile Justice and child protection I
don't know Nathan if you're going to
to Chairman Edwards would you like us to
go through each account
or or would you like to keep it at a
higher level
I you know I definitely want to hit some
some of the high points here like uh I'd
like to crosswalk these Personnel lines
because as I I just was trying to do it
um ad hoc earlier I didn't I didn't see
how the where the numbers lined up for
the personnel and then I noticed that in
between Pages there's the domestic
violence program that I don't see listed
amongst these and so I I I'd like to ask
about that too since we're covering
those pages sure so um if you turn to
page 875 of the governor's recommended
budget
um the the first accounting unit there
the emergency cyf fund this is actually
part of uh hb2 from this past
legislative session and this was
established it was a fun to support
families in emergency situations
the the second if if you turn to the the
um this is the this is the overall
Office of the director
um I don't know if there are any
specific questions uh there we do have
some position movements
um and on the on the position movement
document that I that I handed out
um there are a number of positions that
that are moving into this accounting
unit and then we've identified the
accounting units that they come from
there are also two full-time temporary
positions that will be being converted
to full-time authorized positions one
thing just to keep in mind for the
entirety of dcyf and this is my
oversight
um we do have 50 positions that are
being abolished from sysc that that are
not filled today and we had talked about
that I think last week or the week
before
so
so I I do have your your sheet on the
Manpower and and so when I look at page
uh 876 number of positions I guess
that's the office of the director
um there's a plus-up of of eight in
there
um am I supposed to see that on this
sheet somewhere yes so so if you turn to
Au 2956 the yellow highlighted box in
the top left there we have the three
positions transferred from 295 seven the
two from 2960 the one from 7905 and then
the two temporary and when we say nine T
they're they're the temporary full-time
positions that were converted so so that
that is your eight
okay because I I count
I count three two one I think that's six
but I'm seeing eight
and I'm I'm not I'm not I'm not trying
to Sharp shoot it I'm just trying to
make sure I understand the numbers and
and then if you look at page 876
um under Office of the director
accounting unit two nine five six down
at the bottom of that page you'll see
the state fiscal year 23 adjusted
authorized you'll see the 27 positions
and then in 24 and 25 you see the total
35 positions right so that's that's plus
eight right yes
so I see a plus six under Au 2956 I
don't see plus eight so there's there's
the the six positions that you
identified plus the two conversions so
that those so six plus two and then we
have those two conversions becoming new
authorized oh so the conversions aren't
on this sheet
yes they're they're they're right there
the 290 conversions
oh
okay
they are there
so two what is the nine one what's the
nine one mean
is that a nine one my eyes aren't the
nine t en nine T yeah it's it's a Tango
uh temporary but yeah it's it's it's a
common uh nomenclature that that's right
I'm just using the all right I I can now
read your chart and and the numbers
crosswalk thank you excellent
um the office of the director is is
primarily
um
as you'll see it's it's it's primarily
salary and benefits is the key driver
um behind that and when you look at the
the the total funding for 24
um it is uh about 30 federal funds 60
General funds just so so in general
we've got a A plus up in overhead and I
know nobody likes to hear it like that
but so can you explain what the value
I I'll defer to to Joe on on the
rationale behind centralizing those
positions
so these are mostly transfers from other
parts of the division into
um Supervision in this so our chief
legal officer
um who reports to me now oversees our
policy development which I don't think
was true in the last biennium so those
positions moved over also oversees the
central registry that's the registry for
abuse and neglect so those positions
moved over so really it was a round
moving folks under the supervision of a
new person so we're not taking anyone
out of direct Client Services these were
roles that already existed that were
just situated elsewhere in the division
that we just moved under a different
leader okay all right got it
excellent if you turn to page 877 of the
governor's recommended budget there is
the the child protection account
that you will see in the class 10 you
will see a higher than than I guess what
you would expect to be increase in the
class 10 line there and and then
concurrently with the benefits but what
what you're seeing there earlier when
Joe was was referencing the enhancements
um these that is that is the cost
associated with those enhancements for
the child protective service workers and
the supervisors um and that's what
you're seeing show up in that class 10
line
um
I don't know if are there any other
specific questions about the numbers for
okay
so can we get to the domestic violence
programs on the 2959 I don't think
that's in your budget book but it's on
page 879
are we going to have domestic violence
program on another day or so there is it
there's a they do show up in a later
slide under the bureau that oversees
that work if we want to talk about it
then or if we want to move to that way I
just got a short question I uh under
area or excuse me agency income I see
federal state and 22 I see 523 thousand
dollars that goes to zero what happened
to the other funds I know these are
these have at least three different
other funds that feed them where's that
it's got two types of marriage licensure
and it's got the domestic violence
surcharge of fifty dollars
yeah
part of my commitment to these folks was
to protect that
those other sources of revenue and I
don't see them yeah so so this this
account is funded through a variety of
funds
um we receive fifty dollars from
Joshua's Law
and I believe it's a domestic violence
surcharge yes yep and I would I would
have to go back to get an answer for you
on that the other one is from marriage
licenses it gets a big percentage of the
marriage license and it gets a big a
much bigger percentage of the officiate
marriage officiate license correct and
and all those are pretty strong sources
of revenue
and it says zero in the budget so I'm
just curious well what do they want it
that's the adjusted authorized um I I
would have to go back and and look at
the history behind why that adjusted
authorizes zero I think we hit a bill
last year to say stop taking it away
from marriage licenses
[Music]
I sponsored that bill and it did not
pass
information so and and while we were
having that debate I promised that I
wasn't coming after their money right
but now that it's gone I want to make
yes
um so uh Rebecca Lorden Finance director
um so this is the special officiant and
that law was new so we hadn't budgeted
anything but we were earning um Revenue
so this is uh fiscal year 23 so we
currently are earning Revenue in that
category but we just didn't budget any
estimated Revenue yet
it was something that came in the middle
of the um biennium but okay so I'll buy
that on the officiant
but there is the other marriage license
money that's been there for years and
years so it should be in that line
yes and that's why there's three
different agency incomes
there's one for the marriage license one
for the Joshua law and one for the
officiant yes ma'am yes so it's still
one is the Joshua law the zero zero
that was the question I was asking
no it's it's on the same page it's just
a higher line
so so which one of those is the uh
Joshua
okay so you you educated me thank you
representative hole did you have a
excellent
okay
so if this is a topic for another day
like you had intended to talk about it
you can take it off of that list we just
talked about it I think okay
so we were on 290 2957 previously uh
turn in page 878 Child and Family
Services
I don't know if if the committee has
questions
I'm not going to have questions until we
get to page 893 I just want to look at
the positions the 107 positions okay
um but just because I'm rushing through
that does not mean other reps should
rush through
if you end up with questions in between
were there any questions
um so we covered the domestic violence
program or let me see here we covered
that
um on page 880 the governor's
recommended budget we have
Organization for Learning and quality
management and and this accounting unit
was actually broken up into three or
sorry two accounting units three two two
zero and three two two one
um and on the on the document in front
of you you will see down at the bottom
left the 2960 accounting unit
you'll you'll see the positions that
were moved to the two of the new seven
and eight were moved to two of the new
accounting units then three of the
positions were moved to two other
accounting units as well
um and those those funds were
on page 881 there's the Foster Care
Health Program
I don't know if there's any questions
there we did have a lower spend in FY 22
primarily due to vacancies that we were
on page 882 there's the unemployment
compensation nothing too exciting there
um page 883 there's the child Wells
child welfare service
um I don't know if there's any questions
there
okay
uh page 884 uh there's the accounting
unit 260 or excuse me 2969 Child Abuse
Prevention capta if there are any
questions there I'm just
three sentences yep what do we try to do
under the guise of Child Abuse
so if you look at class 102 that is for
an M ladak contract
sure so the M laida contract is to have
um Master's level drug and alcohol
counselors co-locating district offices
to work with families who have substance
use disorders and to work with our staff
in helping understand how to navigate
those issues with our kids
um but the capta grant funds a couple
different things one of them is that
Community Navigator program that I spoke
about before
um it funds I I'm off the top of my head
I'm not remembering home but it funds
different activities a host of different
activities like that support for you
know Family Resource Centers and things
like that
in order to try to you know try to help
meet kids needs in the community before
they come to us as a state we do a lot
of things I'm just not sure which ones
are funded through this grant versus
other sources right the kinship
Navigator programs I spoke about Family
Resource Centers I spoke about the
community Navigator program that I spoke
about frankly in my view the entire
system of care as a prevention activity
because anything that you're doing to
get kids and families the help that they
need so they don't come to us the
deepest end of the system in my view
this isn't about the kids with needs
this is about parents with problems
right both that's a different problem
it's both though I I would say that it's
both right because you have the way that
the system of care works it recognizes
that kids are within families and that
if you don't have a strong family unit
that understands how to manage those
kids needs that you can't actually have
a healthy outcome for that young person
right so key component of the system of
care is peer support for the families
who are engaged in it to help the
families figure out how to navigate
things like multi-systemic therapy that
I spoke about earlier it's really around
helping caregivers learn how to help
manage their kids Behavioral Health
needs and redirect them and help help
them have healthier outcomes so these
things are yes about families and about
parents and they're about kids because
kids don't function without families
I'll I'll come off it I'm just curious
how we tell an adult don't beat your
kids
um and do that in an effective way I I'm
just curious what that program does
really yeah I mean so teaching people
appropriate and safe and and healthy
but that's so that's a key component of
the Healthy Families America program
that I spoke about before right helping
teach parents how to how to
appropriately discipline and get get
Behavior changes from their children in
order to reach the outcomes so the
Healthy Families America home visiting
program Youth Villages intercept program
those are all key parts of that we have
other programs called parent health
support that go in and do that type of
work with family and we're still all
involuntary
relationships between the families and
the state or at what point are we in the
market right so the Healthy Families
America program is is a voluntary
program
but the intercept program that I
mentioned is a program that gets put
into place when there's an open child
protection case so that could be in a
voluntary open child protection case or
it could be in a court involved Child
Protection case but the program is the
same based on the underlying need okay
that that tells me what did you
represent an ordering do you have a
question
stream yeah I I actually want to go back
to 2961 before jumping ahead just one
question on uh on what does the audit
fund set aside uh represent or how does
that come out and how does it get
resolved yep so so you will see audit
funds set aside in a number of our
accounts and um the department of
administrative Services tells every
state agency for the federal dollars
that we receive you need to set aside
point one percent of those dollars for
audit related purposes and then those
and then to tie that in representative
Weiler chairs a committee that
establishes which audits get conducted
and so I think that money pays for those
money goes to the LBA
to going on at these they have they have
a regular series they do like every five
years on every agency and then if if
there's something that they think needs
a performance on it that's another
higher a little bit higher level a
little more thorough and and this
committee decides which ones get
performance audits
question
if you don't mind
aren't these audits specifically the
ones for the federal government
the the the funds that are set aside are
federal funds used for the federal
government so like kpmj that contracts
with the state LBA pays keep you know
they they pay them
um through that the the legislative
performance audits I I would have to
defer to the LBA on the budget there but
my assumption would be that would be
separately separate Appropriations to
the you know to the legislature I mean
the idea here is they're auditing for
the federal government to prove that
we're spending federal funds properly
yes things single about it there's a
single audit for all of federal funds so
okay
um teen Independent Living is at the
bottom of page 884.
um you you will see on page 885 a pretty
significant decrease
um in the contract line those were covid
funds one-time coveted dollars that will
not show up in the upcoming biennium
the uh 2971 on page 885 uh relatively
small dollar amount there I don't know
okay
um on page 886 there's accounting unit
don't know if there's any questions this
is primarily for housing employment life
skills
okay
on page 8887 promoting safe stable
families
uh accounting unit sorry like uh
yeah
I apologize beginning on page 86 there's
promoting safe Stables families this is
a this is a federal award that we
receive
I have just a general question in this
area Okay so a lot of this is our
services that we contract out
and I'm sure as part of our our contract
work we make sure that there are metrics
in place so that we know that they're
delivering on the contract that we've
done with them
do we have clawbacks if we give them
performance measures and they end up
because they end up having the same
problems the state does they can't find
enough people to build the capacity to
meet the contract do do we end up
getting this money back or is it how
does that work
yeah
um many of our contracts are actually
on not on a cost reimbursement model
where we're paying them and then having
to call back but it's on a per de it's
on like a per diem rate so a contract
for a program like uh intercept that I
spoke about before we're actually paying
them only for the families that they
serve and the contract has a ceiling
that we can't exceed
but they don't get they don't get paid
for the families that they don't serve
they only get paid for the jobs that
they for the work that they do
so so then that's good so what's your
what's our experience been are are we
hitting a hundred percent of the maximum
uh are we hitting half of that what I
know it probably varies by contract but
I'm just curious how this Manpower
problem is affecting our ability
contract as well it's it's impacting the
child welfare system and the children's
Behavioral Health System all the way
across the board right so all those
things that I just spoke through those
key accomplishments
um you know honestly I think we've built
an awesome system for the state I think
that when this is fully operational
because we have our Workforce issues met
we're going to be leading the country
and in lots and lots of areas but right
now at every single turn of the system
there's a Workforce issue preventing us
from kind of hitting on all cylinders
right from the child protection
investigator to the child protection
case worker to the sysc staff to the
in-home provider agencies to the
residential provider agencies to our
Care Management entities at fast forward
right this Workforce issue is hitting
every single contract that we have and
having us not actually meet kind of
where we're designed to go because if
there's not enough staff to do all that
work
on page 887 there's the adoption
services account 2974 that this pays for
an adoption incentive I don't know if
page 888 account unit 3220 this is the
Bureau of professional and strategic
development and this is a new accounting
unit this is resulting from
from uh the the splitting up of the
accounting unit 2960 I'm not sure if
there's any contracts or any questions
there
oh yeah that's
that's another one on your sheet adding
people think yes yes that yes that that
is correct
um it's it's in the top right corner
there you'll see the the 11 total
positions that are being moved into this
looks like you're creating a whole new
program for 24 and 25.
yeah essentially what that was is we had
one Bureau that was overseeing a host of
activities
um and we decided that we wanted to
structure it differently so we just
we're moving some of them into this
place and some of them into that place
but it's the same amount of staff
um it was we had one Bureau that oversaw
kind of our training our professional
development work they also oversaw kind
of our data work our federal reporting
and we thought you know we needed
different leaders for those two
functions and broke them out into two
separate but it's the same staff overall
just a different organization you need
to go to hb2 to reorganize all this
was it a separate legislation
no
this is that this is down at the account
Bureau level so I don't believe that is
required it's an excellent question
though
um at the at the bottom of page 888 this
is 3221 and this is another uh new
accounting unit where we were taking
eight positions from from the from the
former 2960.
okay
if you turn to page 890 this is Child
um so can I come back yes there on 888
I'm reading Bureau of looks like
professional and strategic development
am I reading that right the Bureau of
is that a renaming of something that's
yeah that's one of the new so we had one
Bureau Bureau of organizational learning
and
quality improvement now it's Bureau of
professional strategic development and
Bureau of evaluation analytics and
Reporting so it was one now it's two but
it's the same staff just organized
differently under different leadership
much cooler title though okay all right
well I think the folks really liked the
Bureau of evaluation analytics and
Reporting because the acronym of that is
bear
so folks really really liked that and I
had a different name for it I think it
was reporting evaluation and something
else and they came back to me and said
no you have a terrible idea and bear is
a much better name so don't don't poke
the bear all right thanks
three two two one the one I think he was
just talking about there's quite a big
in in three two two one three two two
one am I reading that wrong so so that
that is a new accounting unit yeah
um
oh for the whole something oh that's
child protect no and for child
protection
so where it is
okay
yes yeah so so you you're looking at the
uh the 79 million figure in state fiscal
year 24 for General funds from the 73
yeah and and earlier
um you know what one of the one of the
key drivers behind that you know was was
the enhancements I I forget the
accounting unit off the top of my head
um but but that was one of the key
primary drivers behind what you're
seeing there okay so so this is the
total for the whole department for his
yes for for that for for 42 10 10 for
child protection yes but there are there
are other accounts that are within dcyf
at the activity level
okay
um
all right and then if you skip ahead
okay I'm sorry I'm a little slow again
on page 888 for the Bureau of
professional and strategic development
up above on line zero seven zero
in-state travel reimbursement
am I right to be reading it's 513 024
and 565 and 25 or yeah yes
that's that's sounds like a lot of money
for in-state travel
so I'll I'll let Joe speak to the the
work that that his team does but it
often involves uh going across the state
uh two individuals homes on a regular
basis so some of these people are out
there almost every single day and then
we reimburse them at the federal rate
for their travel
so they're going to people's homes are
they going to employees go ahead let's
go ahead Mr ribson yeah this is this is
the travel related to training
activities so when we have
um new staff right they have to go
through three months of training this is
the travel costs that are associated
with that the travel cost that Nathan
was referring to or elsewhere in the
budget for staff who are moving around
visiting kids and things like that we
actually don't have a fleet of State
cars for our staff the way that you know
other jurisdictions do so we reimburse
them
um mileage rates
that three months is in person in
Concord or something or much of it is
some of it is remote but much of it's in
person some of it's in Concord some of
it's actually down on the sysc campus
where we use some of those older
buildings as kind of mock interview
sites for you know a mock home
inspection and things like that so there
are different parts in the state but but
yes a lot of it's in person a lot of it
requires you know significant travel
okay because I don't have a 22 and 23
number to compare it to the numbers just
jumping out at me
um I I'm just going to ask the question
have you all really looked at that hard
to make sure that in the post-pandemic
era where we all zoom and everything
that that we really need to be moving
humans all over the state yeah you know
some of the charts some of it is remote
and during the pandemic almost all of it
was remote but people have provided very
strong feedback that in-person training
is far superior to the to the zoom
options
now just to quote a famous man I can't
help but to think of who's zoom and ho
but
sure if if you turn to page 893
um we we pick up with accounting unit
7905 this is juvenile Field Services
I don't know if if there are are there
on page 894 there's ojjdp
and and this is a um primarily what you
see here is a is a Federal Grant
may I inquire what ojj the p is
it's the federal office of Juvenile
Justice and delinquency prevention thank
you
and then on page 896 you will see the
sunini Youth Services Center and as we
already discussed for the current
biennium there was an hb2 provision
funding the operations and uh you you
will see an appropriation uh in hb2 as
well funding those operations can you
give us a preview of coming attractions
on hb2 what what what's that operational
budget going to look like
relative to
a standard annual
13 million dollar sure so the the
appropriation that's included in or will
be included in hb2 is 11.1 million
dollars primarily of General funds in
state fiscal year 24 and 11.4 million in
state fiscal year 25 again primarily
General funds in the past we did have
more offset revenue from from kids
coming from Vermont and they would pay
us on a daily basis we really don't have
that anymore so we don't have that
roughly million dollars plus available
so now it's primarily generally funds
earlier I heard that we took 50
positions away from here what what it
doesn't feel like that had a huge impact
on how much we're budgeting though
yeah so they were actually unfunded
positions right in previous biniums so
they didn't they were positions that
existed on the books but they were not
positions that were funded in the budget
so if you'll recall you know you've
you've gone through this a couple times
there's been multiple cuts to syc's
budget over the years but there haven't
been cut to the positions allocated to
sysc at the same time so what would
happen is positions would become
unfunded to be able to meet those
targets that were set through the budget
process and those positions would end up
living on the books kind of making
people think that the Staffing numbers
were a lot higher than they actually
were and we wanted to clean that up so
now that it's clean uh how many
personnel do we think are authorized for
sysc
it was somewhere around 85 I could be
off by a couple
87. how did you guys know 87 so fast
okay the positions are still listed in
the HP one okay and and that's a
function of the state's budget system
you the positions have to show up there
okay great did you have a question I do
thank you so of this 87 that's showing
here
two questions first one is what
positions are filled currently and what
is needed to run the current facility
where it's at
so what's in what's what's in the budget
that 87 is is what we think we need to
fully run the current facility I'd have
to double check back on what's actually
filled right now my guess would be that
it's somewhere in the
probably total of 40 to 50ish Ballpark
um that's not just front line staff but
that's other positions right nutrition
maintenance all those other things that
happen at the facility the front line
staff as we've talked about before I
think are currently 17 on the books that
are filled
um so that's why I'm getting to we're
probably somewhere around that 50 number
but it could be a little bit less than
that I can get you an exact number on
that
hmm
in earlier I think I saw the number six
you have six new you correct me so you
had six new clinicians to help you
transition over to the therapeutic based
model
I'm not sure where you got that number
six from but what we so the way the
clinical programs design I'm remembering
your text from earlier in the slide deck
yeah so it's not six we have the way
that the clinical program at sysc is now
designed is we've actually eliminated
the state staff clinical positions as
part of the last
reductions that happened after the last
budget and we entered into a contract
with Dartmouth for fewer licensed
clinicians to support the facility So
currently there is a a part-time 10-hour
week psychiatrist that supports the
facility a full-time psychologist and
so I've heard and I have believed that
because of the instability of the sununu
plan that we were running into trouble
keeping folks from Trading
if we're if we're relying on and I I
knew this to be true I had forgotten
that we're really relying on Dartmouth
to provide much of the professional
support wouldn't they be pretty immune
to all the tribulation we've undertaken
and and shouldn't we have the ability
already to be converting to a
therapeutic based model so Dartmouth
only provides those kind of licensed
clinical level supports at sysc not the
front line staff the front line staff
for state employees so that includes as
I said before 10 hours a week of a
psychiatrist full-time psychologist two
licensed full-time clinicians there's
also a couple Physicians that come
through the facility that check on the
kids physical health I'm not even sure
how many hours they they log but it's
you know a couple hours a week a few
hours a week those are all contracted
through Dartmouth the other positions
are State positions the front line youth
counselors who do the primary day-to-day
24 7 regular interaction with kids those
are State positions not contracted with
Dartmouth
so we've we've covered the the
accounting unit level detail
um and the the the presentation that
that that Joe had
um
there there are a number of uh charts
and performance uh indicators I don't
know if you'd like to cover those now
yeah there's a host of kind of data in
here to kind of walk through so people
can see what's happening within the
system right now I'm more than happy to
go through that although I also get the
sense that folks are have had a long day
so you advise I I um I'm gonna I'm gonna
give division three like two minutes to
flip through the graphs
uh uh up through Page 20 and if you have
any questions on any of the graphs we we
each graph is worth at least a thousand
foreign
I'll tell you a question I'm going to
this this chart looks interesting the
one on the left in particular
so this is going into our new Juvenile
Justice assessment work which is brand
new as of last year right so I probably
will have a hard time explaining that
one without going through the first page
a little bit just to orient folks to
what's happening in that system if folks
want to turn back to 16 really quick
so again the brand new system that we're
setting up using a child adolescent
needs and strengths tool whenever a kid
has contact with law enforcement to try
to divert them deflect them away from
the formal court system and towards
Services what you see on the very first
slide is just how many each district
office had and you'll see some of those
numbers are really small that's because
it was rolled out in kind of a you know
one third of the state at a time right
so that's just the total number the next
page is of all the times law enforcement
referred a family to us because this is
voluntary families could say nope I'm
not interested in which case law
enforcement can move forward with their
traditional process and their
traditional decision but when law
enforcement made that referral test 72
percent of the times the family said yes
I want to go through this process I want
to have the cans done and see if we can
you know come to a to an alternate way
of of resolving this then that leads us
to the next page
so the next page is recommended
interventions following the cans
assessment so of those 72 percent of the
families that said yes and that we've
completed the process for so you'll see
this the net here doesn't add up to the
total conducted during that year because
it's about a 60-day process to go
through this
but this is kind of what we're seeing is
of all those families that come to us
only about 28 are being recommended to
go to court involvement
about 14 are being recommended for kind
of lower level Behavioral Health
intervention that's that green box there
where it says community-based mental
health really what we're talking about
there is individualized counseling
that's probably one of the greatest pain
points right now of getting kids
Services because typically what that is
it's a referral to Community Mental
Health Center and they're really
struggling to get kids into those slots
to get individual counseling services so
if there's a place in here that I think
really needs some some propping up it's
that piece of the system to get kids
that individual level counseling that
they need and that we're identifying
that they need but they end up on wait
lists for a long time
so I hear you the problem statement
what's your solution recommendation I
think that's something that you know
really talking through this with our
Behavioral Health Partners is probably
better than anything that I'm going to
come up with since I oversee the
Community Mental Health Services but
that is definitely that is definitely
probably our biggest area of need is
access to individual outpatient services
for kids and it's really not even just
the Community Mental Health Centers
that's the primary place but you see
this phenomena happening of private
providers refusing to take any insurance
at this point right going solely to
private pay which for many of our
families is not an option
um so it's it's it's a big issue in the
mental health space right now so so I'm
just trying to also understand if if
there's some good news buried in this
pie chart that the 28 percent of the
court involved this is based off of the
711 or the 72 percent that the family
agreed to get involved with that means
they had a real relatively positive
outcome for their kid except for 28
percent of the time correct yeah I think
this is really really promising data
about the way that this new program is
working in terms of being able to
identify alternatives to court
involvement for young people and what I
think is really exciting about this when
I think about the next few years is that
these are young people who this is
oftentimes their very first interaction
with law enforcement what would
typically happen is young person might
have an interacted with law enforcement
law enforcement might
just say look they'll talk to the
parents they're not going to prosecute
them but these kids will come back
they'll come back they'll come back and
nobody will have ever done an assessment
of what's really going on there and what
these kids need now we're actually doing
that assessment getting those families
engaged with Services when these kids
are young so I think this is kind of
where when I talk about you know five
years from now our system being
different this is one of the key things
that I think is going to get us there is
those families who historically might
have had repeated contacts with law
enforcement before anybody even bothered
to look at look at what those kids
needed are now having that work done now
and this assessment process it doesn't
only do the assessment and identify the
resource but they'll stay open for a
period of time to make sure the family
is connected to the resource which is
where I get this data from around or
this anecdotal data around the biggest
pain point being for outpatient services
for kids because our staff are telling
me that's the thing they can't get their
kids into of all these services so with
all this priority on finding other
avenues
um what what kind of scenario
um is is leaving that 28 percent there
what what what kind of
immovable Force are we dealing with so
what the assessment's really looking at
is a couple things right it's looking at
the needs of the young person
the strengths that we can build upon
with a young person and also the needs
and strengths of the family unit
so what would what typically you're
looking at here is you know young person
had contact with law enforcement
oftentimes there's some type of violent
element of that right they're going to
fight after school or something like
that that brought law enforcement to
their door when they're coming to us
we're doing our assessment we're not
seeing a long list of violence we're
seeing kids with high levels of
depression and anxiety and other types
of you know challenges like that and
we're making referrals out to that that
28 typically what you're seeing there
are either you know more serious
offenses
or kids and families who are
so an armed robbery right something like
that that's going to definitely go get
into this or you know sexually based
offenses where you know somebody is you
know a sexual assault of another
individual things like that are going to
fall into this category it's not just
defense based though it also looks at
the Readiness and willingness of the
family and the youth to engage
voluntarily in services so if you have a
situation where yes they agreed to go
through this process but what the
results are telling us is that this
young person this family are not going
to actually show up to individual
counseling they're not going to actually
show up to the fast forward program that
we're recommending then that's a
situation where you know Court
involvement is helpful because the judge
can then kind of
get those services in place so that's
what that 28 is looking at
representative question uh yes just
understand here you got a body of people
here
you got a body of people here are those
the same people or or is they are
so this is a subset of the big box here
right
this is a subset but this has more
people in it
this has over a thousand people in it
and this has uh what is it got um no I
think what you're seeing here is these
are not all unique so a young person can
go through a service or go through this
process and have multiple referrals
okay so you could have one young person
who were saying they need to be involved
in individual mental health counseling
and they also should be part of a
restorative practice through a diversion
program okay so that's why the numbers
this is 72 this is the set this is a
part of the 72 because these are the
completed assessments and the 72 is
everything that walked in the door and
what happened to the others the ones
that didn't get uncompleted they're they
were still in process at the end of the
calendar year so this is calendar year
one data so people who walked in the
door and say December weren't done yet
in January when this data was pulled
um but the other big things here right a
lot of kids are being identified for
higher end Mental Health Services that's
that orange bucket here for things like
fast forward that's the kind of formal
big system of care that we talk about
a lot of kids actually just showing up
saying that they need to have some kind
of involvement in some community-based
activity right which could be a Boys and
Girls Club it could just be get the kid
involved in Little League so they have
some kind of pro-social activity that
gets them out of doing nonsense right
and gets them into something that's
healthy for them
um you see a big category here for other
that's a lot of creative thinking from
our staff about ways that ways that
young people can kind of heal the the
damage that they caused you know a lot
of times kids have contact with law
enforcement because they did something
foolish
they might not have a big Behavioral
Health need they were being impulsive
they were following the lead of their
peers you know going through the
juvenile justice system or even a big
formal intervention isn't necessary but
you know working with that young person
to figure out how do you how do you kind
of cure whatever damage you caused with
the people that you harmed through your
behaviors
um and then the smaller sliver here for
voluntary JJ Services you see that's
only two percent early on I talked about
something called voluntary chins
so if we want to get a person into a
very intensive evidence-based model like
multi-systemic therapy that I spoke
about at the beginning of it this is the
pathway to do that because right now
that model is only available through a
formal Juvenile Justice case at some
point in the future I would love to be
able to move that program into being
accessible through the system of care
but we're just not there yet in terms of
implementing this new model for folks
um and then the diversion programs
that's what I talked about before those
are kind of restorative justice type
models for kids in the community that's
the place where we do have a prioritized
need to try to beef that up a little bit
because we have real challenges with
Equity across the state in providing
those Services you have some parts of
the state that locally fund these things
and do a great job and you have other
parts of the state where young people
just don't have access to the service
because it's it's not a local priority
so it's getting close to four o'clock
so
if is there are there any questions in
this area
okay so I'm going to jump to 22.
slide 22 and I am jumping a whole lot of
information there but
um in the Bureau of community family and
program support one of the things that
these community-based Services is meant
to do is to help us get uh involved in
interrupt human trafficking
what's our New Hampshire experience is
this is this a
even a case is a big deal but is this uh
how how would you re-rate New Hampshire
relative to other states
so we definitely see cases through the
child protection system of kids who are
engaged in traffic and kids who
oftentimes what you see is folks who are
looking for kids who are vulnerable
because they're part of the juvenile
justice system or the child protection
system they don't have strong adult
supports around them and they try to get
those kids engaged in commercial sex
activities and things like that we see
you know I wouldn't say a massive number
but probably at least a dozen instances
like that each year for young folks in
the state
where that's a where that's a serious
legitimate concern so those are tend to
be organic kids that have grown up here
that have been brought in or enticed as
opposed to somebody who's been brought
across the board or the state lines to
correct okay yeah and we have a we have
a staff person who focuses specifically
on that work and engages in there's a
task force a state task force around
this issue that coordinates with law
enforcement around investigation
prosecution and all that stuff and I
would assume there's a high correlation
with the drug use yes all right yeah
okay are are there
other issues questions representable
thank you back to Pages 19 and 20. right
great page 19 we've seen this graph
before multiple times
um page 20 looks like there's an
averaging per month for that same data
set
if if I'm reading the graph correctly
what I'd like to know is since roughly
July 2020 and if your team can put this
together
right how many times we've crossed over
the 15 threshold
versus 18 right I'm looking at page 20
where it shows we're basically under 15
the entire time and then more
specifically right is this let's say a
weekend
where there's no there's no you can't
get to a court there's other options
that prohibit you from being able to
address the issue at hand so there's
some backlog because the event happened
over a weekend and it's Monday before
you get to be in front of a judge to
deal with the issues I'm trying to see
if right where these events sorry where
the numbers cross over the 15 threshold
and why if you could I could I could go
back and have our staff you know have
our data folks kind of pull the
instances of where we cross the 15
threshold and get you that I will say
you know anecdotally we do see more kids
get detained on Fridays and Saturdays I
don't know whether that's because people
don't have access to judges because we
actually do have emergency contact with
judges 24 7 365. I think it's because a
lot of activities occur on Fridays there
is definitely a component of kids
playing on the weekends Friday and
Saturday I get that but there's also no
way to disposition that easily within a
courtroom you can get an ex parte order
there's lots of things you can do
right 24 7. what you can't have is a
fair and impartial hearing Saturday
morning so there will be a backlog
between Friday night and Monday morning
to start dealing with some of that I
just wasn't sure whether this was
weekend Peaks or something else going on
yeah I can go back and try to get that
data for you but you know like I said we
do definitely see you know weekend is
the is the highest likelihood of a
detention a new detention coming to us
we I want to wrap up in the next five to
six minutes if not sooner is are there
other questions that jump out from
anyone on these slides there's some
several of them with the whole entire
departments on it that may be of
interest
if if you don't mind indulging me for
one second I just a couple key points
I'd like to make from the data slides
for child protection I can do it in two
minutes
all right
um if you look at slides number eight
and nine
that's really telling the story of
what's happening at Child Protection
intake
so that's the hotline
and we do see 2022 actually being a
record high year in terms of calls to
the hotline and the chart below that
that's that's calls per month to the
hotline blue is 2022 pink is the the dot
on the January at the top that's last
month so we do see right almost every
month in 2022 and now the first month of
2023 are really kind of peak numbers in
terms of calls coming to the hotline
which is something that does have me
concerned about
um you know Workforce and what we're
seeing in terms of just new things
coming into the system the next page
looks at the assessments which would lag
a little bit behind the hotline in terms
of this peak so you do see the total
number of Assessments in state fiscal
year 2022 on page 10 being you know
higher than 20 and 21 but a little less
than 2019 what has me a little bit
worried is when you look at page 11 and
you look at the month by month that goes
beyond the state fiscal year but goes to
the last seven months every single month
of the last seven months we've had a
higher assessment volume than typical
right so it does have me worried that on
the assessment side we're seeing higher
than typical volume as well as on the
calls into intake
and then on the next page this is family
service cases this is where we actually
open a case because of what we
discovered during the assessment process
was that either abuse neglect was
occurring or that if it wasn't abuse or
neglect it was severe enough that we
wanted to open up and offer a voluntary
case for a family that's a small number
of the total but that is part of it and
you do see here fortunately while the
total in 2022 you know it's higher than
it was in 2021 but still below where it
was in 2019 when you look at the monthly
growth on the next chart page 13 we're
seeing a similar story where the state
fiscal year data is kind of at the start
of an upward Trend and that the last six
to seven months every single month it's
going up so if you look at the chart 13
and you look at the Blue Line you do see
kind of growth almost every single month
to the pink line the pink dot at the top
of January of us kind of getting back to
where we were a couple years ago when we
were near our Peak numbers so again if
you think of the system right the call
is the first thing you see spiking
assessment numbers are the next thing
actual cases are the next thing so I do
have concerns looking at the recent data
about growth
um in demand countries and structures
is there a new structure or a growing
stressor what we're hearing a lot of
from our staff right and this is
anecdotal I don't have
qualitative quantitative data on this is
kind of the Acuity of what's walking in
the front door feels heavier than as in
years past right so while the raw number
of substance use cases is lower than it
was a few years ago the substance use
cases we're getting are much more
serious
as a whole right lots of folks involved
with fentanyl use and other types of
really really serious substances which
would yield more kids having to come
into foster care in those situations
than if you say had one parent who was
struggling with substance use and you
had another protective parent who's able
to support those kids while the parent
while the ones are struggling going
through Services
seeing increased demands and again also
around the mental health system in terms
of unmet mental health needs of parents
contributing to the ability of of them
to kind of keep their kids safe and
parent their children and also hearing
and seeing
um
real challenges around kind of shifts in
the economy for some of these folks and
not being able to just you know meet
basic needs of their kids sometimes
so fentanyl is is the big drug in the in
the news
um what's secondary what's what's the
second biggest drug that we have to
worry about well the ones that I worry
most about right so there's right
there's drugs all types of drugs but the
type that tends to have a kid have to
come into the care are your more serious
drugs right so when you see folks using
methamphetamines and when you see folks
using fentanyl those are really
concerning drugs
um the scariest thing I've ever seen in
my life was a parent who was using PCP
that was back in New Jersey
unfortunately we don't have a big
problem with that up here now but those
there's a difference between you know
some drug use and others and there's
some substance use that you can work
with a family around and and try to make
sure you have a protective person in the
home maybe it's a grandmother or
somebody else and there's other things
that we're seeing more of today that are
just just scarier and harder to be able
to feel confident leaving that child you
right
you know okay uh Mr so so thank you you
all can go about your day enjoy your
last 30 minutes or whatever uh Mr Ripple
you got any words of wisdom for us we're
getting together again
tomorrow
tomorrow at 10 to hear public health and
uh nope I don't have anything else to
add
tomorrow is Public Health
It also says dcyf continued are we done
so I think you are looking yes you're
done and I think you're looking at the
original calendar schedule which
unfortunately I had to send out or I
asked Janet to send out a revision so
tomorrow is public health only and
Wednesday will be Behavioral Health only
okay we start at 11 tomorrow then or do
we start at 10. still 10 o'clock okay so
we start at 10 with public health what's
your sense now that you've seen
how we're rolling is that a three-hour
deal a four-hour deal well in the past
because there are so many accounting
units it has taken a long time to get
through but it really depends on how
many questions the committee asks there
are there's not a whole lot of General
funds in public health it is mostly
federal funds so it depends on how much
you want to dive in so this is the one
where on average the matching
requirement of General funds the Public
Health Federal money is about 20 percent
of the 80 percent for federal is that a
is that a rough percentage uh it's that
sounds right it is overwhelmingly
federal funds overwhelmingly yeah
okay uh question
thank you just based on the open-ended
nature of the day tomorrow and the
impending weather
do you we're going to be continuing
after the lunch hour into the afternoon
just for people who may need to plan
okay so in general I try to ignore the
weather because the speaker's paying
attention to it and then they issue
guidance guidance so I tend to I tend to
just assume that we'll follow whatever
Guidance the speaker gives and I expect
tomorrow to be pretty typical in terms
of us taking time off for lunch if if if
if it looks like that's a poor thing to
do and the smart thing is to drive
through because we're making better
progress in public health and we could
just get out sooner I'm open to that
I I don't know that I would think of it
on my own immediately so feel free to
speak up if it seems like that's a
possibility
I'm thinking about some people who drive
a little further
yeah so what's it supposed to do
tomorrow it's supposed to be weather
so so the snow that we have to deal with
we have to deal with coming in will
there be an accumulation probably while
okay but while we're in here are we
expecting more accumulation
okay
so
uh so just stay tuned I mean who knows
the speaker May cancel because of the
people driving from the North Country I
don't I don't I don't presume to know